End 0.9% of the times.
Ready?
Are We Broadcasting Rico?
What's already out there?
Ladies and gentlemen,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and to enter
in the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex till I from men.
Shazamm Russell Peters is in the house bitches along with his friend Jr straight
out of London,
straight out of the dirty streets,
London,
Ladies and gentlemen,
internationally known and locally accepted.
Russell Peters isn't the house my brother,
let's go in on,
what's the word,
younger fella who were just talking about how we were in a grocery store or it
was like a little convenience store and Vancouver and there was only 20 bucks in
this little tiny little shelf that they had their,
you know,
the limited amount,
like a couple of Dean coon's books,
some old lady romance books and Bam,
Russell Peters,
Ladies and gentlemen,
you bear book,
what's it called?
Men,
why?
It's called funny.
You should ask Joe.
It's called call me Russell.
Call me Russell for poor people.
There's people that still are not aware of the full Russell Peters experience.
There's a lot of,
let's call them white people,
but a lot of people that don't realize you are probably right now the most
successful comedian in the world.
Like who does more internationally than you?
I don't think anybody does.
I think the only person that comes close is,
what's the guy with the puppets?
Oh,
Jeff Dunham.
Jeff Dunham does.
He wrote were internationally.
He's,
he works really loud.
Yeah,
to just baffled.
I've never heard of him apart from like on the Internet and stuff.
Well that could be the same response people have for me too.
I find that London is London who is one of the smartest cities I think I've ever
done.
Comedy and not London is a very smart city.
It's a very intelligent city.
I couldn't see that puppet show going on over in London.
I might be wrong.
You said?
I think he wouldn't ever did Edinburgh festival,
but outside that I have no knowledge of him gigging anyway,
so he's like,
he like he couldn't do the o two and lots of us was in,
in,
in the UK last year.
He did two sold out night for the l two which is on the,
I'm certainly not hating on them,
by the way.
Sam,
this is awesome.
What does it say?
Russell Peters said the green card to her live from the o two arena in London.
I know.
Interesting fact.
I had Michael Buffer do my intro that night.
Really?
Did Bruce feel like you were cheating on him?
Well,
no.
That's how I actually met.
Bruce was from my,
from a hiring Michael to do that and then Bruce and I became friends.
Oh Wow.
That's funny.
Yeah.
Bruce was going to do,
there was some guy was trying to organize something for Bruce to introduce me in
Vancouver,
but I'm like,
man,
that's just too much crossover.
That's just getting too weird,
but learn the lines too.
It's too in your world,
but I shouldn't,
I,
you know,
I'm not hating on Jeff Dunham when we were saying that like that I would be
surprised as act would go over in London,
but I always thought of him as more of like,
sort of like a kid's comedian or like a real family comedian,
you know,
just like,
like what's his name is Willie.
I got like,
I have no problem with people at puppets.
No,
no,
no.
I like it.
All right.
It doesn't,
it doesn't look on the radio though,
I find.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
But like if you ever seen Natto in George [inaudible],
George,
isn't that the guy with the puppet,
the black guy?
No,
no,
no.
I know is you're thinking of Willie Tyler and last,
that's why I was thinking Willy Taekwondo and George is a guy out in New York
and auto has been around for a long time.
I know his name.
We did.
Um,
these,
uh,
Dangerfield prom shows where you used to,
the way they used to do it is the show would start at like whatever,
seven o'clock,
eight o'clock,
and they would continually pump in more prompt students.
They never got him out of there.
They're just pump new ones in there and forced them to leave.
Everyone was talking and everyone's standing up.
Al Lou Belle was on stage.
The guy got on stage,
took the microphone away from him and blue cigar smoke has faced some big
fucking high school football kid.
I mean,
it was just,
it was the craziest gigs you could ever do.
And I did them with that guy and he has a,
he's like got an evil poppy,
like the pub.
We'll say fucked up shit.
And he'll say,
hey,
what are you saying?
Yeah,
that's all.
but he's a master of it.
I think all those people that do puppet acts,
nobody can fuck with auto and George,
nobody's made me laugh more consistently than that guy.
That's where the puppet insults the puppeteer.
He insults everybody.
Hey,
what do you mean I got a small Dick?
You can't say that.
Yes I can.
I've seen it.
Yeah.
Puppets are supposed to be saying shit that you feel uncomfortable about saying
it and then you make the puppets and you go,
hey,
you know what?
That would be good for,
uh,
for nowadays because with all the political correctness and everybody coming
down on everybody for fucking,
that'd be great.
Using their words.
True.
Tracy,
Tracy Morgan is going to Nashville now to stand in front of all these gay,
lesbian alliance people and standpoints and
just to prove his point and he's going to,
apparently he's gonna to make some big ass apology.
It's why.
Yeah.
I don't understand this.
I will talk about this the other day.
I don't understand it in stand up.
You're meant to be able to say what you want and I'll just explain to people
right now that don't know the story.
Just tell everybody what the story is tomorrow.
A knowledge a couple of little bit.
Last week,
two weeks ago,
he was doing the show and he did the show and he said that if he's,
if he heard his,
one of his son talking gay,
he would stab him.
Yeah.
The Sun came out and said I was gay with stab them to death.
But you know that it wasn't said like that.
It wasn't said in a serious tone.
He said,
yeah,
it's exactly what [inaudible] yo,
that's crazy be I was stabbed I little motherfucker.
Now if he said that on,
on,
on Larry King or on the tonight show or,
or I don't know,
CNN,
whatever.
I could understand that.
But he's saying it in a show as part of the joke and whatever.
And you knew it was like a black room.
You have to say the outlandish shit though.
You can't just be like,
man,
I would just embrace him.
I mean,
they gotta go,
you gotta go way the fuck over the line.
If you can't see
the exaggeration in that one.
Come on.
Even in the UK sort of like,
you know,
black people and we move is up in the black people in America.
Um,
we would expect something of that kind of ilk,
you know what I mean?
We wouldn't have figured out exactly.
Sorry,
I can hurt a black guy.
Say I have to explain it.
This a shot.
I shot an elk,
fried it up.
Nah,
there's something going on lately that where people are way more sensitive.
Jo Koy gender,
whatever.
What did he get in trouble for
saying faggot?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
He and,
and his was the,
the worst thing for Jo Koy is,
um,
it was like said so casually and in a,
and it's not like it's specific.
Jo Koy it's probably something any comic in that situation would have said to
apparently Joe coys fly was down on stage and somebody said,
hey,
your flies down.
Some other guy went,
yeah,
you're flies down and gentlemen.
Oh,
he like that faggot.
That was it.
And then he continued on with this act.
It wasn't like any,
it was just so people got mad at him for saying that some writer was in the
crowd gain lesbian writer and ended up on Huffington Post and Perez Hilton.
And then here's the worst part.
Joe was one of the lead actors and Chelsea's knew a sitcom on NBC.
NBC fired him.
What
does that mean that before that,
can we just go on stage?
Now we have to say that.
Well,
you're a faggot.
Is that basically it?
Yeah.
Shit.
Are you fucking,
that's crazy,
right?
Holy Chef for best is going through a really rough time now and really if you've
know Jo Koy,
the audience,
99% of the audience thinks he's gay anyway when he walks out,
right?
Yeah.
Look,
he's just trying to get a laugh out of a weird moment where someone's heckling
him,
man.
Just see cause you fucked up and said the wrong thing.
That's not like a statement.
It's not like he's releasing a press statement.
This is something I've carefully considered and a,
you're a faggot.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
this is just him trying to be funny in the heat of the moment.
Yeah.
I mean,
I say it all the time just to my friends,
like I just,
it's just one of those things and it's not even like,
you know,
like Louis C k said,
it's not like we mean anything negative,
but it's like,
you know,
you just like your friend and be like,
yeah,
I got to go and take my wife to the mall faggot.
And you say it at the Times where it has nothing to do with being gay.
Queer.
It was beeped out of my,
my TV special,
the only word that we,
it was uncensored on comedy central from 11:00 PM on and on.
Spike TV.
Same thing.
11:00 PM on,
you can say anything except faggot.
They beeped out.
Faggot Nigga.
You could say mother never said nigger.
It wasn't in the out.
I didn't test that.
I bet they would've beat that too.
They do it.
They wouldn't allow that.
But they allowed fuck and shit.
Suck my cock and the craziest shit ever.
I don't know.
I didn't say cons,
but they sat on sensor,
they said uncensored except hate speech.
And they said that fag,
it was hate speech.
And this is the craziest thing,
and this is true.
The Guy,
the network said it's our word.
And I said,
what?
And he goes,
it's our nigger.
He goes,
only were allowed to say it.
I go,
that is the gay shit I've ever heard in my life.
And that was a real conversation.
I
really said it to me like it's our nigger.
And I'm like,
get the fuck Outta here.
It is not as an England cigarettes or fags.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's it.
Well,
and not only not in England,
the word cunt comes flying out every five minutes.
If you're out drinking,
as this says he's a Brit.
Great Con.
Telefind.
Yeah,
if you're not,
you're not down.
Well,
I think England is a much better use of it then.
We're doing,
we're speaking anyway.
I'll let you eat.
We're hiding from it.
Ooh,
don't say it.
It's called the greater country.
And I got in trouble.
I just said this writer's cunty or writing his country and everybody was so
fucking angry,
mean crazy.
And I'm like,
you guys need to relax,
man.
This is,
this is just a silly word.
You know,
if I said Bitchy,
I would've meant the exact same thing.
I didn't country sounds less a mean.
That bitchy ain't fact.
Yeah.
It's like bitchy implies you're a bitch.
Khan Khan's.
You're just being country though.
It's playful,
it's playful.
It's like if you,
the way I say it is a,
you've,
you'd go up to someone's daughter or go up to someone and say,
your daughter's a cunt.
You know,
like he would have been way,
what the fuck?
But if you go up to someone and say,
Hey,
your daughter's a little container,
and you're like,
yeah,
I got to grow up with her kid.
Can't he makes it sound like,
exactly.
You should meet her mother.
And I was one of those things.
It's like,
yeah,
you know,
chasing,
get cunty my cat can get cunty.
My cat gets conti and my car gets county,
but it's not a cunt.
Right.
This is a big goddamn difference.
People are so fucking sensitive.
It continues to just cut like a con Twitter.
Similarly,
like
my Ford edge is a faggot all the time.
Is it?
Yeah.
15 miles a gallon for that fucking knew.
That's like you're ridiculous.
You knew what you were getting into you,
but got an Seu bought a giant box,
but back then it was $5 a gallon.
It was a little bit better than that.
Yeah,
but it doesn't make your car gay.
It means you've planned out.
It's a faggot neck.
Have a talk about your petrol prices over here.
Okay.
Is it worse over there?
Oh my God.
England's been getting fucked in the ass on that for a long time and by fucked
in the ass,
I don't mean anything.
Like what is it to a gallon over the,
okay,
I have to do the calculation.
What is it per liter ready is about one pound 41 40 40 is about $3 American,
right?
Isn't that correct about bell 280280280 okay,
and that's per liter.
How many liters?
Two liters and a gallon,
right?
Isn't that worth over two lanes?
How many lights up?
4.5 liters to a gallon.
Gas is like $8 a gallon plus eight 50 a gallon.
Hold faggotry thank you very much.
Thank you.
[inaudible] you can donate any,
any guests to me whilst I'm here I'll take it back and just gave me a cookie
with nuts and fruit and all.
We haven't enough cash short.
Like
I got in trouble on Twitter the other day.
A bunch of people got mad at me
because a I posted,
I posted this study that showed that um,
very homophobic men are more likely to be aroused by gay porn.
Did some sort of a study where they showed men they put like a sensor on their
dick.
They showed them all kinds of things and the guys that were really homophobic
when they showed them like guys fucking,
they actually got excited.
Awesome.
Which totally makes sense.
It's kind of like,
and people that are a so anti whatever are usually kind of pro those paper.
Exactly.
Almost always.
And so,
uh,
I put that up on Twitter and I said another study that confirms something we
already knew what's next.
Studied shows.
Many black people don't tip,
you know,
so this is,
I just put this on Twitter and this fucking one bitch sends me this Twitter
message.
You fucking racist.
I hope you have so many cuts your dick off and shoves it in your mouth.
I was like,
Whoa,
whoa.
And then I said,
note that I said many and before anybody even attacked me,
and I said,
I'm not saying all just many like this isn't racist.
This is just truth.
We know this.
This is a cultural fact.
There's many black people who do not tip.
But what about black being from England?
That's a zero.
Yeah,
but it's a cultural thing.
We went out for breakfast.
You have it in England.
They don't tiptoe in America.
Most people tip and it's like people feel like there's a lot of black people
that go to restaurants that stiff them and it doesn't mean all of them.
Old people were aware of the fact that you can't,
you can't not talk about that because it makes some people upset because it's
so,
it opens up the door for racism because I don't think it's being racist and just
tell the truth.
Oh well that's what I say.
That's why I talk about the things I talk about it.
Yeah.
Your act is huge with that.
I mean you,
you,
you must have so many fucking people pissed off at you left and right all the
time.
Funny with my fans is the eye.
They get pissed off when I don't talk about them.
But the one thing I've noticed about you is that you let me talk about the group
that's in the room.
Yeah.
I don't
feel like we're breaking up.
I'll move in.
I'll do the side talk
and what is going on?
Why is everybody so fucking sensitive is it is it feels like it's escalating.
The person that commented about Saint Clooney,
racism itself,
was it a,
a black personal black girl
and it kind of couple of black guys and they don't even know your situation.
They don't know nothing about it.
That's the worst part.
That's the part I actually find funny about that.
People are ridiculous.
They always want to be mad for whatever reason.
They always choose to be mad and there is a lot lost in text.
You say something like that in text?
Yeah.
You don't hear tone,
right?
If you were on stage and you said that the exact line,
people would laugh,
they'll go,
oh,
you fucked up.
You shouldn't say that math.
But they'd be laughing.
But when you write it down,
it looks like you're like making some sort of a KKK statement.
You know it's this,
it's fucking silly,
man.
Why we just,
because there is racism and they're fucking most certainly is.
It doesn't mean that black people are off limits for making fun of,
that's fucking silly.
That's so racist.
Cut Somebody out.
Making fun of him.
You shouldn't.
Black people shouldn't want that anyway.
But that's what I like about what was Lucy Carol,
one of your shows says about you hate when people use the n word instead of,
not the Nigga but the n word because it makes him have to think of the word
Nigga.
And I think when you're trying to skirt around issues instead of just coming
out,
I'm saying it plain then you,
you know,
you can't treat your origins like that.
Children.
Exactly.
I had a bit and one of my last cds about there's three magic words,
uh,
con love and nigger.
And the nigger is the only one that black people are only allowed to say.
And it is some weird thing,
but if you say it,
people feel like they are allowed to hit you or they're allowed to physically
isn't.
Very few words that are that strong.
Where if you sat in front of someone,
not even calling them someone just say,
boy,
there's a lot of niggers around here.
They will jump on you and beat the fuck out of it.
I don't even know the word.
I don't even know what snigger cause there's only one letter away from a fight.
All right,
well how about niggardly you know that's a,
that's a terrible word.
Stingy or for,
it's like frugal,
right?
Or something like that about Nigeria.
Yeah.
Nice.
You're please.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a weird thing,
man,
that we have.
I just call my friends Nigerians.
All right.
I'll say nectarines later.
Well,
how about a Ninja
Use Ninja?
Like come on,
but when were on your,
um,
your def jam,
then you had a whole thing?
I did def jam.
Do you see my desk come down?
You did.
I did.
Definitely hear in oh seven.
Wow.
My whole set was about the word nigger
out of 800 black.
Wow.
Whoa.
Let's take it a chance.
I know that's my inner fight are coming out to go and get tan more before you
went on stage.
Now I broke it down for them because you are Indian Bro.
You can confuse the fuck out of some dudes with the right haircut.
That Mexican dude with the big nose was.
Yeah,
man,
he was ballsy.
You just fucking rock a high top fade and come in there with some fucking
converse all stars on you.
Confused the fuck out of a lot of people.
It went well.
It was was the opening joke.
Well the,
I don't want to make you do it,
but what was the whole case?
The
thing was about how white people don't want black people do use the n word and
and and,
and the whole thing is I say,
you know,
it's easy enough for white people to stop saying it cause they created in the
first place I go,
but they're going to come up with some shift.
They can come up with that the first time they're going to come up with some
shit that they're going to say right in front of you and you're not even going
to know it.
They'll be like,
excuse me,
could you pass the vinegar?
And then when I was in Boston,
there's a true story was this white dude.
I said,
here's a prime example of white people coming up with words that you don't know
about.
It's white to kill it.
And he said,
how's it going over there?
And uh,
with the comedy thing and going through I was pretty good.
And I go,
actually I'm doing not def jam next week.
DEF Jam isn't there for the Mondays.
And I go for what?
For the Mondays I go,
I don't know when they air.
He goes,
Nah,
know how to fuck on Mondays.
I love that show.
I go,
the fuck is a Monday.
He goes after what we call black people around here.
I go,
what if I go on Mondays?
He goes,
cause nobody likes Mondays.
Oh my God.
So that was my closing bit.
Ah,
that's hilarious.
I guess standing on,
that's some waitress said that in Vegas cocktail,
which is called black people celebrities.
I've heard they call them Canadians.
Canadians heard the column Canadian because Canadians,
I've heard that too.
Yeah,
not me of course.
But up in Canada,
do people tip?
I always tipping them up generously.
It's not the same.
Okay.
I tipped quite generously cause cause I don't want people to go,
Russell Peters was here.
What a fucking douchebag.
Yeah,
exactly what I mean,
I do the same thing.
Okay.
Well,
selfishly,
whilst I'm here help a brother,
20% to 20% that's what I do and it was a bottle of wine.
It was that I going to give me 20% extra food.
No,
but you know you to look at it in terms of the,
the wait staff,
it's not their fault.
The restaurant charges x amount of money per hamburger or whatever.
You know the wait staff is working for,
they don't make money.
Minimum wage.
Yeah.
Like the other day,
I don't even get that man.
They get,
they have to pay,
their paychecks are usually zero or like a dollar because they make $2 an hour
that just pays the tax and so they,
they pretty much only make whatever,
it's still illegal.
These still,
I knew none of the,
yeah,
that's why.
That's why I still do it.
Like,
yeah.
That's why waitresses are what they work on tips.
That shit is ridiculous because that's just like,
just because a waiter can make a lot of money,
it doesn't mean you shouldn't pay him to be working in your fucking bar.
That's ridiculous.
Just because they can make a lot of money on tips.
Doesn't mean you shouldn't be paying them to work for you.
It should be illegal.
We went to Jerry's and they didn't have anything I fucking ordered on the menu
and she wasn't a good waitress,
but I still left her a nice tip and union was like,
yeah,
I go down to age,
still going to tip her.
I'm like,
you got to.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that makes sense to me.
That don't tip.
Have you ever waited tables?
No.
Do it.
Do it for five years.
Perfect accent.
The waiting tables,
people you respect and trust and English.
Welcome to El Pollo Loco
and American.
Where you live.
You live in London?
Uh,
not live.
I live about 150 miles north of London now.
Okay.
So,
but you grew up around that sort of area.
How often are you in America?
Oh,
well,
three,
four years ago.
What's the biggest difference?
Um,
gas prices.
price of everything.
Yeah.
And also the,
the service that you get over here is fast and period.
Then it says tips.
Yeah.
That's why you got tip people.
Have you ever,
had you ever gone to a restaurant in England?
Oh my God.
It's the worst.
It's not that bad,
but it wasn't.
I think,
um,
our freedom speeches
is if it's false superior than other here though freedom of speech and the rest
of the world.
That's why when I,
when I watch these things on the news and I'm like in there and we've got to get
the terrorist,
they're out from thereafter our freedoms and they're mad that we have these
friends.
I'm like,
you don't have any,
I've been in the Middle East.
They've got way more fucking freedom than that.
You're doing American.
Really?
You think so?
Fuck.
Like what?
How do they have more freedom of freedom of speech?
You can that kind of shit.
Fuck yeah,
you can.
Here's the thing.
In America,
there's only certain things that are off limits.
Uh,
you can talk about Muslims all day,
but you can't talk about Jews.
You go to the Middle East,
you can't talk about Muslims,
but you can talk about Jews all day.
You know what I mean?
Right.
It's just the exact opposite.
But
in the Middle East,
you talk to him.
I don't,
I don't bother with it because not my business,
but because it,
fuck that shit leaks back to America and she will get you fired in the future.
Yeah,
right.
They'll hold some future contracts over you and fire you,
but you know,
you can really say whatever.
I said,
whatever the fuck I want,
but don't you think that it's more dangerous over there?
And we're just like,
we've had guys that did sets like what's it did?
How sparks tell us that,
how sparks went over there,
man,
they were going to lock him up in jail because he referred to one of the,
uh,
what it,
what is it?
One of the prime,
what centers are a member of the religious family?
Some high,
all he did was call him Sir or miss you or something like that.
He,
yeah,
he referred to them in a formal way,
but in not the correct way.
It's not like you're royalty or whatever you're supposed to say.
You're,
you're,
ah,
what have you,
what are you supposed to call them?
Your Highness,
Your Majesty.
It's one of those things,
like if you don't refer to him as that,
they'll lock you up in a fucking jail.
And the club owner was telling him,
look,
we'll probably be able to be able to get you out by tomorrow,
but you're going to have to post bail and you might have to leave the country.
And he was like,
what?
And when someone's a little bit,
and they didn't even get hurt.
Someone complained.
They called the religious police.
So they showed up.
Yeah.
So,
um,
it was with the religious police,
political,
whatever the fuck police it was.
They showed up and they were going to lock this guy up.
But members of the royal family were there and they were laughing with them and
they were talking about how funny they thought his act was.
And so then the policeman went,
the,
the royal family thought it was funny.
We're not going to lock them up.
This is stupid.
This is ridiculous.
It's really about,
you know,
who it's the same.
So like what's going on now?
People just decide to be upset.
They decided to be outraged.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's,
it's less over there,
you know what I mean?
I don't feel any pressure on a narrow.
They really,
they are,
they only thing they tell you is,
listen,
don't talk about the royal family and don't talk about Islam.
I'm like,
cool.
Yeah,
but I don't know either of them.
Perfect for me.
I feel like,
I don't know.
Yeah.
But I still think that their,
their freedom of speech is it's,
I mean,
they live in their marquee.
They have kings.
I mean basically,
I mean they
part like,
I mean when I hung up,
hung out with the king of Jordan,
like he had me over to his,
to the palace and cooked me dinner.
Oh,
the lean pockets.
No,
he had these cookies with nuts and fruit.
Dude,
you are hanging out with the prince of Jordan.
King,
King of Jordan.
The prince was there,
but the king and the queen.
Wow.
And what does that,
let me tell you about this.
He's cool as shit.
Really.
He's the one of the coolest dudes I've ever.
How many do you think he's killed in his lifetime?
I don't think it's probably his family has he,
he's pretty chill dude.
Finger off the trigger and he went to school in Boston.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
He,
he grew up outside of Jordan for the most
what a lucky roll the dice to be a royal member.
Royal Family member.
You wake up here,
the prince?
Yeah,
he's a,
but that's the thing I was like,
cause Gabriel Iglesias was with us and Angela,
you know angel lists or Rukus Big Fat Greek guy.
Maybe Andrew was with us and we were all at my brother.
We were all just hanging out and the king was cooking and talking and making
jokes.
He was considered dudes with machine guns all around a pile of cocaine.
There was there
was there like a disco downstairs and he hits a switch and all these girls,
there was a shooting range in the basement.
Become really a shooting range.
Yeah.
Not like a one lane.
It's like a big ass shooting.
Jesus Christ.
Does he have any sort of crazy pimp set up?
Any sort of like salt number NY type shit?
No,
no,
no.
He's cool.
He's,
he's,
that's the thing.
He's very American,
North American and western and the way he lives his life.
I seen the guy that's into the gift,
uh,
he sent me,
he gave me a watch.
I want to watch.
Watch is actually,
I want to watch a documentary on the salt number nine.
I want it to salt and Bernada open up his life for a reality show.
So just say you want to see what's up,
what's up?
I'll show you what's up.
He'll open dire straits can do that.
Yeah.
Thousand Ferrari's and he's got gold underwear on and all these pictures come
out naked and they adopt sneaky to
no,
he didn't bat.
You know when he got caught with all this,
when he was hiring all these American girls to go over there and far down with
that dude,
you got to love the game,
man.
You gotta love with the guy.
Did the guy would get magazines and we'd go get me her,
give me her.
And he would get actresses and models.
He would get like porn stars.
She would get girls from playboy and Penthouse and Maxim magazine.
Like whoever the fuck you up and then one of them ratted out.
One of them gave up the ghost and they found out what these girls were doing
for,
you know,
$30 $30,000 a day over there spending crazy.
I'd go straight for the porn star.
The one bothered within the act of,
because I lift the porn stars and know what,
I'd rather turn out a regular chick,
you're paying $30,000 right?
Going to go,
here's the thing,
you don't need to pay a porn chick that much.
They're only making a hundred a thousand bucks a scene.
Fuck you overpaying them for it.
You want to make sure you get return on your investment.
It's like getting an open mic or making them headline.
Yeah,
exactly right.
I think a,
yeah,
this is a Charlie Sheen about that cause I was like how much are you paying
these?
And it was because you'd read in the papers like 20 grand and I'm like,
what the fuck?
He paid them 20 grand for,
these are Ibiza thousand dollars horse.
He goes,
not now.
I would buy like credits
credit.
He would be like,
I give him 20 grand and I'd be like this is for 10 times or something.
Wow.
Swipe his card has a little punch hard pimp game.
There's a terrible pimp game cause you never pay up front for anything ever.
Yeah,
I know these benefits can get run over or something.
Yeah.
The only thing you should pay up front for his art.
Have you guys been to exposed?
I in Canoga Park,
the Strip club that's out there.
They did this guy,
I've seen it but I've never been.
This guy is the smartest guy ever.
He bought a shopping centers like Strip shopping center and it's like on the
right side.
Do you have a weed store?
It's open to teat 2:00 AM so I went there and bought a bunch of cookies and
actually it's called 2:00 AM so don't tell him.
Then you go,
there's a bar that's like a,
they have every single bottle of liquor and drinks you could want.
There's pool tables,
girls,
naked girls on the,
on the walls,
and then they have a topless girls dancing in this bar and then you want to go
deeper.
You go next door,
then it's full nudity and it's all the like coke and water you can drink and
stuff like that.
It's like this big amusement park in the middle of nowhere where you just get
weed and strippers.
It's awesome.
Wow.
An amusement park.
Yeah,
it's like an amusement park.
They have a strip club was,
it was a fun strip club.
Well it was a Monday night,
so it wasn't like much going on,
but you know,
I was just saying how awesome that is.
I guess on weekends it's Great.
You know,
there's nothing weird.
Or then when you go to the Strip club and no one's on the pole,
dancing is only like two of the guys in the audience and you're waiting for the
next dance would come out and try and get their shit together and you're like,
no,
you really shouldn't be there.
Yeah.
I remember I was in Adelaide a few years ago doing the comedy festival.
Adelaide in Australia.
Oh,
okay.
And the one of the saddest size,
they have a soul in between the Polo.
Dalton says a guy comes out with a squeegee bottle and a cloth just to kind of
reclean the pole.
I've seen that with Windex because they have to cause some of these dirty
bitches of the herps and the other other girls go,
I don't want to be sliding down and get the herps off of this media,
whatever,
everything.
You name it.
Right.
It's all on that little thing,
that swab.
You got to kind of kind of question your career choices if that's what you're
doing.
A free,
yeah,
I guess.
Unless you have like $5,000 in your pocket.
That's the big question is like what is more degrading?
Is it more degrading to slide down a pole for $5,000 or to work at Denny's for a
hundred yeah.
I mean there's,
I know a lot of these girls now,
I know a lot of these girls I love to dance.
They love nudity,
they love to dance and so to them they're like,
you know,
I don't care about my body.
If you guys want to look at my body,
that's fine and I'm making how much money.
Okay,
this is great.
I'm so,
I like that the dom says,
I'm talking about the guy that comes.
Oh,
the guy that comes to three he's clearly replaceable.
I was just,
I was on editor.
He gets all uppity one day.
Yeah,
like what?
Man,
you you,
you find me a guy who could clean his polar.
I got to do
Roger.
You're crazy.
You're not going to read them to you or Roger.
I'm just not using,
I have oil.
I mean cleaning his Po for 18 years.
Man.
There's some secrets to the game.
Why mother fuckers be twisting it and you got to go straight up and down.
Yo,
y'all don't even appreciate y'all.
I appreciate what kind of skill I'm bringing into this whole bond.
You don't even know the right mixture.
I ain't no a hundred percent Windex to see it and try it.
Use it 100% Windex on that mother fucker.
Watch what happens on my ass shaking tutor.
You need to keep that porchlight Luma feed that you even know about.
All that
bitch bitch can pull the lip.
Meet curtains,
ducks.
I saw that last,
like one of the girls was doing one of those things where you're sliding down a
whole thing.
You could just see her little pussy lip just retching and it must hurt hanging
on the thing and it's numb like a Meu tie.
Fighters,
shins
kicking banana trees and shit all her life.
She can't feel nothing in that posting giraffes knee.
That's the reason why she fucks.
She tries to stay alive.
She just wants to feel something.
I just need to be loved internally.
Did you ever wonder about a girl that you can't fuck hard enough?
Like God damn,
bitch,
what are you trying to chase away?
This ain't normal.
This isn't an exercise.
[inaudible] Whoa,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
We got to talk.
Can we cuddle for a Bullock?
What the fuck are we doing here?
I came into your life without knowing the script like you're going to have to,
you have to show me what the fuck happened in chapter one.
You know,
where's your boners manual?
Real close to murder right here.
What the fuck is going on?
Truly taking a run up,
choke you and fuck you to death.
What's going on here?
I'm crazy.
Hooker.
What are you looking for from me?
Right.
I'm with you twice as good to be married,
isn't it?
You know,
you know what you're in for.
You want to hear depressing news that my dad gave me?
Yes or no?
Yes.
Super depressing.
Okay.
All right.
So I call him for father's Day and he goes,
did you hear what happened to your niece?
And my niece is like 21 and she's a lesbian and stuff like that.
And we've talked about before.
And uh,
she,
her and her girlfriend lived together and worked at this place called Tim
Horton's,
which is like this.
Yeah.
It's like your family's Canadian.
No,
they haven't been,
uh,
Columbus,
Ohio also for some reason,
but it's,
yeah,
it's a coffee place,
but it's like a fast food coffee place,
you know,
it's like whatever minimum wage.
So that place closed down or something like that.
So they had to relocate to another one and they,
the,
my niece,
his girlfriend was making all the money for the family because she got laid off,
my niece got laid off and so she had to take this bus to go to Tim Horton's.
They closed that Tim Horton's and now she has to ride her bike to this farther
away.
Tim Horton's and she's been working at night shifts as you and riding her bike
back and forth.
You know,
I like super late at night and they were so poor that they didn't have a light.
So they taped that flashlight on door bike.
So when she was driving at night and so on,
so she's driving home the other day at 1138 or,
I mean riding her bike and this guy hits her from behind going like 45 miles an
hour.
She flies off and goes crazy down the street.
He gets out of the cars calling nine one and she's like,
am I going to die?
And saw this other car fucking runs over her.
And then the second car runs over and drags her body down like a mile down the
street and that car takes off.
But anyways,
it's like now and then,
so then she goes,
and then my dad goes,
you wanna hear what happened?
Your nephew?
Well,
because of the Japanese earthquake,
uh,
he worked at the Honda plant doing really well.
They don't have parts anymore,
so they had to lay off everybody at the Honda plant and that he was on at.
So he gets laid off.
And so both my niece and my nephew,
my nieces now suicide,
and my nephew is now both going back to my stepbrothers house to live and it's
just like the same week.
And I was like,
well,
what's,
where did she live?
Huh?
No,
she died.
Oh,
and they're looking for the guy.
So in Columbus,
Ohio,
and then we'll be right.
[inaudible] brought to you by the fleshlight.
I know that you said you want to hear some depressing news,
but somehow or another,
I thought there was a point to it.
Someone got run over by a fucking car five times.
If you see a car with some lesbian [inaudible],
please call the Columbus blue
trail on the front.
It times are tough for everywhere,
especially if you're in a bad spot.
That's the number one thing.
If you're in a spot like Columbus or high or spot,
it doesn't have a lot of jobs.
You need to get the fuck out of [inaudible]
from Columbus,
Ohio was buster Douglas and Brian Redman.
Wendy's.
Oh yeah.
Right.
And that's another thing.
This is Tim Horton's.
You're making $5 an hour.
If you're riding your bike five miles to go to Tim Horton's,
find another job by your house that you make.
Same amount of money.
There's just no jobs.
Yeah,
you're saying that,
but you don't understand how bad it is out there in some spots and sun spots of
the are no options,
man.
There's people with PhDs that are taking job waiting tables.
I was telling my mom that she goes,
oh,
we're better than Detroit.
Yeah,
that's Troy.
It is so bad.
It's almost the Caveman Times Detroit.
They just,
they just released the Detroit has 47% illiteracy.
Literacy.
Illiteracy retweeted that when you're,
I can't believe that.
And you said it doesn't matter cause they'll never read this.
Don't your Twitter or something like that.
I retweeted.
It was hilarious.
You know that's a crazy thing,
man.
Wow.
That's a crazy thing.
That's a really scary thing.
Those people are only as smart as the people they know.
They can't read anything.
They can't go on Google.
They could watch documentaries.
Maybe they can learn something from that,
but other than that,
they can't read.
If you can't read,
you can't learn anything.
If you can't learn anything,
you can't check facts.
You check facts.
You're fucked.
You only as smart as the people hang a right.
Does that happen?
You know why people are shit parents,
man.
That's how it happens there.
Their children having children,
that's what it is.
There's a mother of five,
by the way.
Awesome.
Let's stop.
Stop,
stop.
Stop.
She was a lesbian,
so she had boys in all of her her whole life.
She gave up on Dick after a while.
I was drowning.
Questions not as dangerous as bike riding.
Apparently too soon.
Very soon.
Yeah.
Let's let that sit there for a second.
It's sucks.
Yeah.
If you're in a bad spot,
man,
you've got to move.
Can't be riding your bike to Tim Horton's and five in the morning,
but you're,
you're wrong man.
When you say like surely should be able to get another job.
No,
I mean it minimum wage job.
I mean it can't get jobs,
but there's only so many minimum wage jobs go away.
I don't think Kim Tim Horton's is minimum wage.
I'm sure they pay a little bit better than that.
It's like a Dunkin donuts bagels and stuff.
You don't think Dunkin donuts would pay over minimum wage and I was a Canadian
company.
It's probably not gonna pay that one.
Mcdonald's barely
minimum wage.
And that's a little bit of socialism going on in Canada,
but not full bloom.
No.
Were you shocked at the riots?
I was.
For the people that don't know there was giant riots in Vancouver when it looks
lost game seven.
Yeah.
They lost the hockey and the Stanley Cup and hockey means a lot to Canada.
It's,
it's,
it's there,
everything.
But I mean,
what the fuck are you riding for dude?
Yeah.
What are you doing?
Are you taking out on right at the,
at the players when they show it,
they show up.
Are they going to do man in lost a fucking gay?
I mean it's,
it's just a game.
Why is everybody gone so crazy and what are they mad at?
All the fucking players in Boston or fucking Canadian anyway.
Yeah,
it's true.
Right?
You know,
we didn't really lose,
I was there want to riot.
I was there for game five and that was in vim carton or was in Vancouver for
game five and I didn't watch the game,
but I was,
I was working on my material before my set and I was hearing people scream out
the window like for hours and hours,
people were screaming in the streets like happiest,
fuck,
cheering and screaming.
Like they couldn't be happier everywhere you went.
Everybody had a big smile on their face.
So for me to come back home to La and then to hear that it was it on Tuesday,
whatever it was,
whatever day it was,
the head of the riots,
I was like,
Whoa,
I was just there five days ago.
They were all so happy,
you know?
But I'll be honest with you,
I think if they had one,
they would have still been riots.
Really?
It didn't really make it happen.
That's how it was for the buckeyes.
And the same thing with the Lakers when they,
when fucking people riot.
What is it with sports teams drawn?
Retires,
right.
I don't like team sports either,
so I didn't really make a difference to me.
Yeah,
you're always going to the UFC.
You don't,
you don't watch other sports.
MMA and boxing really boxing as long as number one to me.
And then I really,
are you looking forward to a battalion or a bladder?
Be Klitschko DNA.
That's going to be good.
I'm glad to hear Vitaly Vitaly,
you know Vladimir Vitale.
[inaudible] I want to fight,
but tell me is fighting,
uh,
how do you say his name to Matt said Thomas Adamak add a Mac.
Yeah,
he's gonna beat the shit out of Adam was a cruiserweight.
He's gonna knock the shit out of a bigger cruiser weight.
Yeah.
David had gotten bad a punch on him.
How tall is the guy that David fighting?
[inaudible] know him.
He's huge.
He's six foot seven Ukrainian ridiculous athletes.
Yeah,
he's in Ray.
He is fucking ridiculous.
And he's really smart.
And they both have their doctorates or something.
Yeah,
they were.
Then they want to be politicians.
It's crazy how one of them can take a fucking hell of a punch.
And the other one just can't know.
The other one folds is the one with waiting.
It's hurt.
Yeah,
but fatality.
You can hit that dude with a fucking missile.
Yeah.
And it just,
he just laughs it off.
It's going to be a good scrap for about three rounds.
You think so?
Yeah.
I think David Hayes really overstepping his mark.
Do you really look at,
she's too small for him?
I think so.
What was the break punch.
But they need to,
they need this,
they need to create a super heavyweight division now because it's,
it's,
it's missed.
Its disproportionate.
How much is a um,
Vitaly way,
Vladimir way?
Uh,
they,
they weigh around two 42 volt of them two 42 feet close on name.
Yeah,
but they're lean.
Right.
And David Hayes,
what he's,
who tend to come in here maybe to 20th if he's,
if that's heavy for him really could come in and around to 14 but do you know
that in some sports they think that guys who are smaller have a big advantage
because they don't have to pump blood through all that muscle?
It's true.
But I'm a good big man.
When I was being a little,
I don't know,
because they want to reach,
I mean I didn't know much about boxing,
but the,
the reach obviously on the,
on the big guy compared to Haines,
it's going to be ridiculous.
Well,
you know,
I agree.
But you know some,
some people like,
like Cain Velasquez,
so perfect example,
UFC heavyweight champion.
He's not big.
He's about to 40.
But,
but Cain puts a pace on guys.
If they can't keep up with,
it's like you makes you run with them and then he drowns you.
But canes,
he's solid.
He's a solid diesel,
but he's nothing compared to Brock Lesnar.
Brock Lesnar might have been 45 pounds of muscle heavier than him.
That's huge.
Meanwhile,
cane beat the shit out of Brock Lesnar inside of one round shit out of it.
Yeah.
He beat the shit out of him,
you know.
I mean he's,
he's got a pace that he can keep up.
So you gotta think with David,
Hey,
maybe David.
Hey can put a pace that Vladimir can cause uh,
Vladimir is proportionately large,
right?
A Brock is disproportionately large.
Right.
I use a lot whiter than he needs to be,
but it looked like Manny Pacquiao and I'm Margarito that's a perfect example.
That's a good example.
The guy who is just,
he's faster.
He also has the intestinal fortitude to go forward like that.
Yeah.
I think,
hey,
uh,
hey has been rocked in the past.
Yeah.
And that's by lighter guy.
So,
but you don't think after all this shit talking and he's just going to jump
right in.
I saw,
I will say the more somebody talk shit to more trouble therein.
You think so?
Yeah.
Okay.
A lot of guys do that.
Then when you're scared they talk shit.
Of course.
I think that's what it is.
He's trying to get inside Vladimir said,
but vitamin those guys grew up in a fucking war torn country.
You think you're going to intimidate them?
It's funny watching them talk shit though.
My friends see them.
Did you see the video?
Cause one's got a British accent,
the other one's got a Ukrainian acts.
I don't want to get to the,
I want to hear some good old fashioned American accent shit.
Talking Floyd Mayweather styles should I saw,
um,
I saw one of my friends fight flat mirror and knocked him down three times.
Who's that?
Viral Williamson and they ripped off the Verilyn the decision.
But uh,
he wants a rematch with him so bad.
But you know,
if like it's never going to happen and it's just a Vladimir you think just can't
take a punch that well.
Yeah.
And,
and Darryl was like an awkward fighter.
Fucking hey,
you shut the way to go Joe.
Okay.
It's right here.
Hello.
Hey Man,
dude,
your podcast.
Can you give a shout out?
It's my cousin's birthday coming up.
Okay,
thank you.
Hi,
this is Tony from the shake weight.
I hope I don't get any more phone calls.
I had to answer that my,
my gait was getting fixed.
I got to keep the coyotes out.
Right.
You know the Mexicans at smuggled people into the country.
Yes.
You
know,
that's the people that they smuggled drugs,
coyotes or their mules,
mules,
bringing drugs in there.
But right now it works and they're beautiful.
We know on that.
I'm learning so much here.
Do you do gigs in Mexico over?
Nah,
they don't.
They don't speak enough English really.
And I don't speak enough Spanish.
There's no,
uh,
this,
I've never heard of anybody doing standup comedy in Mexico.
I think Lopez has.
Oh,
I bet.
Right?
Does he ever do is act and full Spanish?
I don't know.
I'm sure he probably could he speak Spanish show Diaz will fuck up a Spanish
crowd and he's done.
I've in Miami,
I've seen Joey Diaz do like five minute chunks.
Just straight in Spanish and a regular show.
The Spanish.
Oh yeah.
Joey's awaken are cute.
Cuban.
Oh Yeah,
mine.
That's in Miami.
He's got that Cuban flair as they go crazy for it.
No,
they never laugh at anybody harder than Joey Diaz in Miami.
This is true.
There's something that happens.
There's a chemical reaction with that crowd because he looks like a big Guinea
too.
A little bit.
Yeah.
We,
it looks like a big Cuban too.
Can we say the g word?
Do that.
Okay.
What does that God,
no leap Guinea.
Guinea.
Yeah.
We can say that way.
I'm just checking.
Yeah,
times have no problem with that.
They call each other guineas,
but you can call them my Guinea to,
they don't care.
Yeah.
I don't even get that.
I don't even know.
I don't get the reference Guinea pigs.
Isn't that my grandfather said they used to call him a Guinea wop that does what
they call them grandfather.
Italian.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I'm mostly Italian.
One quarter Irish,
three quarters Italian.
That's what the Rogan comes from.
Everybody else's right off the boat.
Well,
they're all immigrants.
My grandfather came from Ireland on my father's side and everybody else came
from Italy.
My grandmother came from Italy.
My grandmother and my mother saw no scramble grandmama whose grandma was crazy
bitch.
Crazy as fuck man.
That was,
she scared me away from relationships for most of my life cause I would be when
I was a little kid,
my parents got divorced and we stayed with my grandmother and my grandfather for
a little bit,
for like a year.
And when we were staying with them,
my grandmother used to fucking scream at my grandfather.
She would just,
just,
just crimped,
she would go crazy and yell at him and say,
she's going to leave.
I'm going to move in with my sister and,
and I'd be like,
Jesus fucking Christ is this what happens when you live together?
And this was some shit like this was what was registered in my mind.
This was a relationship when I was five,
I had my mother and father who just broke up cause my father used to hit my
mother and then I'm in with my grandmother and my grandfather and my
grandmother's screams and my grandfather,
my grandfather just wilts.
He just takes it and eats it and every now and then he said something back to
please just stop it.
Please just stop it.
Throw one of those in there.
For the most part he did.
How'd you exercise that out of your mind?
Well,
no,
I think,
I think it's the perfect balance is when you grow up in DC,
shitty relationships,
then you all,
you think about it,
and I don't want that.
My problem is I grew up with my parents.
My parents were together for 40 years and my dad died.
My mom loves my dad.
You know what I mean?
So all I know is that relationship and I'm like,
I'm never going to fucking handle that.
That's not possible.
But it is possible.
It's certainly possible.
You got to put that energy out there though,
and you've gotta be,
you gotta reject anybody that doesn't go along those lines.
People get developed patterns and relationships and they want to,
they want to continue those patterns with you.
And some of them like to fight.
Some people just like to fucking fight.
Do you want to see how that's not me at all?
Not me at all.
I don't like it.
I would assume that that's me.
I don't,
I don't like any of that shit.
I don't like it when my friends,
I don't like it with girls.
Like I was just talking to someone the other day,
uh,
a buddy and his wife and his,
his wife says something crazy.
She goes,
so does your wife let you just do whatever you want to do?
Does she let you,
you know,
go do shows and play pool?
And I'm like,
this is,
my wife lent me.
I'm like,
what kind of alien talk is this?
Let me,
my keeper does my keeper,
let me free is my keeper.
Let me work.
I kinda thought about it and I was like,
what does that was a friend.
What if it was like this?
Brian,
let you go do shows.
There's Brian let you go to dinner whenever you want.
Like what did you do?
You not like me.
Why do you want to tell me?
What the fuck I can't do that?
I want to do like what kind of a weird distinction is that?
But in her eyes,
that's the commonplace.
The commonplace is that the woman gets to dictate to the man what the man does.
Oh yeah.
Does your wife let you drive that car?
Oh,
Joe,
does your wife let you not for the podcast.
Have you ever had,
have you ever had a chick tried to tell you not to buy a certain car?
Did you imagine that?
Um,
I just bought a fucking crazy car and which this guy,
I bought a rolls Royce Phantom Drophead converted.
I love it here in La.
Yeah,
but I'm getting the Stereo read in it.
Oh,
you're an animal.
You're a fucking savage.
She'd do it.
The old stereo,
it sucked.
It was honestly the worst thorough.
Even,
even the Guy Rolls Royce goes.
Yeah,
it's a common complaints.
Pretty shitty system.
I know they don't have to.
It's a Rolls Royce.
A classical music.
What do they need?
It's really weak by them though.
They should provide the full ride with everything.
Bad Ass considering it's the Rolls Royce of fucking Rolls Royces.
Yeah.
I had a Porsche once and had a terrible stereo.
It was like the most wonky is shitty.
Shittiest tinniest stereo.
The stereo they put in a new one is fucking it.
I just heard this new stereo that you can get where it mimics your iPhone so
that it's just a broadcast and it's touchscreen,
so you just go there like open up iTunes,
go to,
you know,
shows up on your navigation.
It's like an Ipad,
but it mimics your iPhone.
That's a good pocket to do.
Lost driving.
Yeah,
right.
Exactly.
Let me just Google my friend.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like we need one more fucking a Google traffic.
How many times do you see someone who even in and you see this
motherfucker looking down at his phone,
looking at the road,
look at down his phone,
like you ate a piece of shit and they've said the people that are,
that you're texting and driving,
it's like equivalent to being like five times over the legal limit of alcohol as
far as the likelihood of crashes.
Yeah,
it does seem about right.
Yeah.
That the,
you know,
Ford has that new technology in the fucking focus where it reads your text
messages to you when they come.
That's good.
Kind of sucks is I have a Ford in.
The problem I have is that they stop it.
You can't update it.
So in like a year you're,
you're shit's not working with all the newest stuff cause they don't update the
software.
The fact that you don't want your fucking text messages,
other people are in the car with you.
I saw your cock.
It is so big.
I wanted in my man.
When are you coming home?
Does your wife know yet?
I love frank
and then I look at her.
Oh Frank,
I love the droid feature where you can talk to her text messages.
You can uh,
it as a text.
That's really good.
I gotta pee.
Excuse me.
That's my new iPhone operating system.
Oh,
but finally these fucks,
by the way,
have you ever seen Greece?
I'm sure you have,
right?
He's the musical.
Yeah.
I've never seen grease John Travolta.
I recently just watched it and I,
this is my question,
was it always supposed to be just kind of like a everyone,
did people believe that those people were high school kids?
No.
I know what you're saying.
Everybody looked like they were 30 years old.
Like look at this guy right here.
Like this guy looks like,
like he's 45.
He's got like a beard coming in.
Like my biggest problem,
I have the problem that grief came out in [inaudible] 78.
Yeah,
I'm about to be published for the last 2023 years.
Long time.
I've had a problem with this field because at the end of the movie she takes up
smoking and she's someone who's tight,
tight path with,
you know,
which means you're going to get thrush or something.
She's going to get what you get thrush fucked in her cunt because I want to mean
look a little like a luck of clotted cream effect in a pussy.
Oh,
thrush.
That's what it's called.
I never knew what to call it.
I've seen that before.
Not pasty.
Um,
cottage cheese.
So we don't,
she does all of this to,
to translate to become more like him.
He puts on a fucking Cardigan.
Yeah.
That's not really like a balance thing for the day.
Right.
She had gone all the way.
She went for horse,
slotted to stuff up to the Max.
So I and equals in a fucking car to good medic life.
Maybe he was like a future hipster.
He just had it,
had it nailed really early on.
Right.
That's like hipster,
hipster clothing.
It was kind of again,
and we're back.
We were talking about,
um,
your back.
We're here.
Stocker.
Channing was fucking 80 when she did that movie
cut back then.
Remember?
Yeah,
it's true.
But it was weird.
He's got a picture of one guy in the hallway who looks like he's 40 years old.
Let me see.
Can I come around there?
Yeah.
And then everybody else,
I mean,
this is just one of the guys.
I like the five guys,
but I mean he has like,
here's like a full beard going on.
He did.
He just,
yeah,
he's
17 and he's supposed to be 17 yeah,
I was 17 when I graduated from high school.
You 17 right?
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
No,
I was ordering.
I just guys,
well,
even if you're 18 this guys,
a lot of guys,
easily fucking 47 he looks like a fucking CIA agent is ridiculous.
I think it was kind of accepted back then that they were playing a part and you
were allowed to do that because there wasn't a whole lot of like really good
teenage actors right now today that a lot of precocious act,
their kids now and they all fucking look exactly the same.
There's a lot of fucking kid actors now.
I saw,
I saw super eight last night,
you know?
Yeah.
That's not a great get what?
I said it's not the end kind of just spit up real quickly.
Like wait,
that just came out of nowhere and I don't know if I like that ending with an
attitude.
It's like,
yeah,
well how about he was eating people one second and then 30 seconds later he's
holding the kid and the kid's like,
I understand bad things happen.
Bad thing happened.
This fucking thing eats people remember that?
Spoiler alert.
Sorry.
But no,
but when you,
when you think about it,
the people that he,
he,
he killed the creature.
Kills are all military when he takes the cup and little girl,
I think they all in that little little,
I thought he's going to eat the girl too.
Let's not talk about that.
Let's where we're giving away too much information.
It was a solid movie.
Yeah.
Don't get me wrong.
It was a real solid x men,
uh,
first club I did too.
I actually went,
first class is bad.
I think super eight could have had 20 more minutes and maybe just the ending.
Maybe you're right.
But I thought that there was a,
there was a couple of cool things about the alien,
but it was also a lot of silliness.
Oh,
she's just like,
come on.
Why did they always do these,
uh,
alien scenes at nighttime?
You never see them on the phone.
Cgi.
That's why they want to make sure that they don't have to.
Well,
you know,
if you go back to old movies where they barely showed you anything,
like the first alien,
God damn,
that was scary man.
That first alien movie,
an American Werewolf in London,
American Werewolf in London was way better than the wolf man.
But the wolf man,
you saw way more of the creature you saw.
I'm like moving around and grabbing and there was something kind of cool about
that,
but the American Werewolf in London was just flashes of this thing.
Ripping people apart,
flashes of its eyes,
flashes of its teeth.
There's something about that,
that it's more suspenseful.
It's more and more rewarding.
Did she ever see battle Los Angeles?
Is that what's called?
No fucking way.
Well,
I saw the ads,
that thing,
I was like,
fuck you got my time.
This is something you've got to do though.
Get really baked.
Go on Netflix.
And there's one of those copy movies that I thought it was the real movie.
It was called battle of Los Angeles or something like one word was different
like bottle battle in Los Angeles.
But I thought,
I thought it was it.
So I started it and I'm just like,
wow,
these special effects,
like really bad.
It's like he wore special effects ever.
I mean like Amazingly Dad.
Isn't there a thing coming up with the guy from um,
uh,
the,
the hospital show er,
no.
Whiling doesn't he have some TV show where there's like the aliens landed and
they're coming
after people?
I don't know if I've seen that too.
I saw previous for it,
it was the previous,
before the previews.
Now if you get to a movie or real early and before they,
even the previous star,
they show you previews of TV shows now and,
and like local restaurants and shit.
And I'm like,
oh,
like it's not even moving.
It's just you're done.
The moon go outside and hang a right.
We have a fine wine selection.
Yeah.
So anyway,
they show that and you know,
I was like,
what is this terrible fucking show?
Like God,
these special effects look bad.
I'm going to just looks unbelievable.
I mean maybe it's good,
maybe I'll watch it and I'll appreciate it.
But there's a big difference between the special effects they do and those in a
movie like you know,
like super eight
and it took me 40 minutes of sitting there watching cause I was too stoned to
turn it off or switching because I wanted to see what that was like.
All right.
This movie was supposed to be legit and I was like,
like really angry that I was like,
why did they advertise it so much?
This is horrible.
And then finally I was like,
I can't take this anymore and I stop it.
And then I was at best buy like a two days later and they had like a preview for
like the blu ray or something.
I'm like,
oh,
that's a totally different,
that's one of those fake movies.
I was one,
but watch it.
It's hilarious.
Well,
if there's ever a movie about a,
like,
like a,
a guy in a horse,
you know,
you know like black beauty or something like that.
Does it ever like some,
some classic that's coming out?
They always like if there's a media movie,
there's always a second media movie.
They tried to slip in
Armageddon.
I don't know which one was first.
You know,
they always do that man.
They always do that.
They always try to like sneak someone in and he'll rush production.
They all came at around the same time.
They'll rush production to to fuck you to put their,
their shitty version of your id out earlier.
But then they'll tell you like what you,
the only one can make an asteroid moving.
Fuck.
You see the point of view?
Yeah.
I think it's mostly for people that like,
like older people that get confused like me.
Yeah.
There at blockbuster and they're like,
oh
well it's sort of like we ever go to a website and you typed in the wrong word
accidentally,
like you left an extra are on right.
And then it goes to some crazy fucking deep anal porn site and you can't get out
of the browser.
You're trying to click down.
Fuck man,
you can't even go backwards.
You're like,
you're in care.
Fuck.
And it's because they like thought that someone was going to write Google with
two L's.
Right.
You know,
so if you're not smart enough and ready,
if you don't Google somebody did that to my web.
So what's you made on my Russell peters.com they put a Russell peters.com with
one l and then they completely cut and pasted them all my shit from my website
to that one.
And what did they do?
Were they doing anything or was this fucking Douche bag guy?
I don't even say his name cause I don't wanna give him any credit.
But he thinks he's a comic and he's a fucking Douche.
So he did that.
Yeah.
Because then people,
because you would go to contact info and he added his number there.
What?
Russell Peters.
But listen.
Yeah.
How many shenanigans is ready?
He's got his notebook and his hand.
He's been
writing new material.
Tommy Shenanigans is,
uh,
you can get them at a discounted rate.
I think about what you were going to pay.
Russell Peters divide that by a thousand.
And Tommy Shenanigans is ready to party.
Tommy,
Tommy Shenanigans.
Well,
Brian reservations.
Bailable Russell Peters with one L.
Dot com.
Tommy Shenanigans.
We'll be here.
Funny any man,
his whole act is about you.
I mean,
he's okay.
Russell Peters is kind of funny,
but come on.
He's got a headstart.
Everybody loves Indian COMEDIANS.
You like,
and it's the same thing.
No,
you're the frozen food.
That guy sounds crazy.
Creepy Stalker Guy.
He's a complete sociopath.
That's scary.
The thing that he would spend so much of his energy to put something like that
together.
He one time he,
um,
he did this thing where he,
he said to some people that were booking when he didn't think I would ever get
back to me,
but he fucked himself because they tried to call Angelo my,
one of my good friends to do the same show with them.
And uh,
and they said,
well yeah,
he's coming and Angelo's coming.
And Angela goes,
okay.
And they go,
Russell's going to be a surprise guest on the show.
And he goes,
what?
No,
he's not.
He's going to be in fucking wherever the fuck I was going to be that weekend.
And they go,
who said that?
Oh,
the guy that we booked said,
um,
if we pay him three grand to do the show,
then he'll get me to be a guest on it.
But you can't tell anybody that he's going to be there.
Because if you do,
that'll fuck up the surprise.
Oh yeah,
it's a,
you pay me two grand and a,
I'll bring Russell Peters if you give me three.
So they gave them three in the same,
but if you tell anybody that he's coming,
then you have to pay me three grand and um,
and,
and that he's not going to sway the,
obviously you knew it.
And so it came back to me and I was like,
really?
And they ended up firing him and canceling the Gig and wow.
But he was like doing this kind of weird fucking sneaky snake shit.
Like saying that he's going to get you to do guest that.
So he,
was he calling you a name?
No,
we were not friends at all.
You're not friends at all?
No.
Yeah,
he was using my name like wow.
Yeah.
No,
I cause cause he opened for me before you meet so many weird fucking people in
this businessman and he's not even a guy who wants to go work the road.
He's like one of these Douche bags and just decided he was going to do comedy
well and he uses jokes off the Internet.
It's fucking hard.
Oh,
was a
complete fucking corn ball.
It's amazing that he's so dedicated as far as like stealing your website.
Yeah.
Well,
we got that ceased and desisted did you
bring the lawyers in now you have a relationship with this guy though,
right?
I mean he opened for me like like three times or something and it wasn't like I
asked him to open for me.
He would like,
he would like sort of stock me and be like,
Hey,
I see you're going to be in Indiana this Friday.
I'm going to be in town there on Thursday night doing a corporate.
Do you mind if I do a set on the Friday?
You don't have to pay me or anything.
Wow.
Okay.
I worked like three times and I was like,
wait a minute.
Are you always where I'm going to be the day before
basically.
I always find that that uh,
do you want,
can I do a guest set thing?
You started stocking march marriage.
Really?
Yeah.
What did he do?
He want it to be on Mark's podcast or something and or open from mark or
something.
And Mark was like,
no.
And this guy went all fucking weird like this on him too.
He's a fucking sociopath.
Did he get Mark Marin with two n's dot com probably two hours.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's uh,
it's interesting how many fucking real sociopath's you meet in this business.
People that just have this eye on the prize and they're just,
they're going to make it one way and they're dedicated to it.
Yeah.
If I never made it,
I would still be a comic work in the road and I would have no fucking delusions
of grandeur.
I would have just been happy doing my job.
Yeah.
You made it or not made it.
I still would have been a comic.
You know how you can tell a real comic.
I mean,
you can tell real comic by watching their act too.
Right.
You can tell a real comic by how,
how you can hang out with them.
And the first time we ever hung out ever was in Vegas.
Yeah.
Right.
First Time we ever hung out within five minutes.
I didn't know him from anything.
You know,
I knew,
knew his name,
he knew my name.
We met five minutes later,
we're fucking laughing and pointing at Shit and Kuvan on things and we're
putting on a show for ourselves.
You know,
you're having fun with comics no matter where you all on the pecking order.
We've all had shared experiences.
We've all kind of died on the cross in a really dumb fuck towns.
And when you meet somebody and you know that there are a standup comic,
like you know,
it's,
there's,
there's something to,
I mean it must,
the only thing they must be like is,
you know,
not to take anything away from people who serve in the military.
I don't want to connect it to that,
but it's,
it's almost that kind of a tight bond.
It's nothing close to being over there,
risking your life.
But there's a weird fraternity.
You what I'm saying?
The military is a bad example,
but it's a,
there's a weird fraternity,
the same experiences in different cities and there's so few of us when we're
actually working,
we're all standing alone in front of a room for the stranger.
Yeah.
And if you look at the numbers,
like I've,
I've talked to people about this before,
this is hard to consider,
but it's real.
300 million people in America,
maybe a thousand professional comedians.
Maybe out of those thousand how many of them are like national headliners?
Is it 200 it may be 200 we might not even be 200 out of those 200 how many of
them are good?
Well that's subjective,
but let's say it's a hundred let's say half of them suck.
So you're one of a hundred people in the fucking country.
That's bizarre.
That's bizarre shit.
That's a very strange position in the end.
And also how many people who set up the rooms that you set out?
Yeah.
A lot of that is just so you can get lucky.
Like Paris Hilton could sell a lot of room to,
if she was,
she had pink comes out of a poster is going to be a shit children.
It'll be shit show.
Yeah.
She's not going to get return customers.
That's the thing is,
you know,
if he just going to bomb,
if you can bring the hype and have an act to go with it.
That is certainly the case.
But there's so many of these,
a reality show people,
they could pack giant places if there were an orbicular answers.
It's fucking strange is what it is.
I mean it is,
it's like a joke has not just become a joke that it hasn't just become
mainstream.
It's actually taken over to the point where it's the majority of what I see on
television
with your TV,
there's no light,
there's no creativity.
There's a story,
there's nothing.
It is lazy.
But producers who were like,
we don't need to hire anybody for this.
It's like,
it's like if you live in a place where there's a lot of Vegan restaurants and a
lot of like really healthy restaurants and healthy choices,
you know,
you're more likely to eat healthy food if you live in a place that is,
all they show is housewives of Beverly Hills and all they show is,
you know,
New Jersey,
Jersey shore,
you're you.
I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
It's almost like the same thing.
It's like I got to cut.
The choices are minimal.
I have to confess though,
I am addicted to mobilize to what mall does it show?
Cool mob wives,
mob wives.
Oh yes.
I've been watching that mob wives and real housewives of New Jersey just to let
me know how happy I am that I don't have to fuck any of those monsters that I
don't have to date any of those.
New York,
New Jersey,
Boston,
Connecticut,
those beast women,
those ethnic beast women,
you know him.
You know what I'm talking about.
It's not all of them.
There's a lot of lovely women in Boston,
lovely women in New Jersey and loving.
Then are we saying that many women we're talking about those Italian angry beast
women,
those screaming,
yelling,
very specific Italian American thing.
It is a classic.
Canada are very different than that.
Yeah,
they're all first generation.
Yeah.
Is that what it only other,
their parents are all from Italy and then all the kids there,
you know,
they grew up with a slightly more respectful,
what's in Italy also of 2000 and whatever as opposed to an Italy of 1920s when
my parents came here.
Yeah.
My grandparents came here running my grandma x.
My grandparents came here and before that they were in the early 19 hundreds so
it was pretty heavy.
Schultz,
Gold American.
Yeah.
That,
that's,
there's a bunch of savages that live on that east coast,
man.
That's what it is.
It's a terrible place to live.
The weather's horrible.
Five months of the year.
It's snowy and cold and shitty and everybody's angry and there's too many people
stuffed into one place and that's what makes those beast women,
those New Jersey housewife.
Beast women.
Yes.
They're cunty.
Yeah.
You're more than tired.
It's against your vehicle.
Remove the y cons.
There's a choose different scene that in country,
you know,
and all the guys are these little juice head guys.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like Megan Fox is probably Cunty,
right?
Yeah.
One of those real housewives of New Jersey.
That's a con,
right?
There's a difference.
Yeah.
But did you think when they get to a certain age and the sort of the wide,
you've dropped it as soon as you know,
want to fuck them anymore.
They're kind of cute,
but he's still want us get them to suck your dick once,
once that's out of the ballgame.
You know,
like a,
now she's just a con Ted wrinkled,
old fucking useless bag of skin.
Now I know why they,
the ends with a why.
Why,
why the fuck are you here?
There's no one perfect fucking place to live though,
man.
Every place has its drawbacks.
Too Shabby.
It's the weather's wonderful.
The,
uh,
the traffic is unbearable.
I think you need money to live in the city that you do.
You need money.
You do need money.
And the haves and the haves nots are very widely separated.
Yeah.
It's funny now because when I go out,
um,
and I go to a restaurant or something,
I see the Paparazzi outside
I in the minute they see me,
they put their cameras right.
Uh,
no,
not him.
He's got a great level of fame.
You've got this sell out the old two arena,
you know,
didn't you do staple center to yeah,
I could do that.
And that was out staple center and then did you can,
you know,
go to Nobu and they were like,
and your name is and you,
you would be in your with who?
And I,
you know,
and I look at the people that they're kissing their ass.
I go,
really?
I got a black car dude,
black card.
I got my black card with me.
Is that black card is when an American Express and American Express is what does
it,
what do you have to deal with that you have to spend a certain money to spend a
certain amount initially to get it and be invited to have really how much do you
have to spend?
Um,
I think maybe like a quarter of a million a year.
Do you remember what happened?
Billy Russell Peters,
he's just bawling base made out of a titanium dude.
If I had one of those,
I would be wearing furs everywhere.
That's all.
I'm going to get some fake don still.
You still have to pay the bill.
That's a problem.
But I could ride that shit into the rocks for like a year.
I know a duty did that,
did it.
He was going bankrupt.
He invested in a porn company and the porn company got robbed at gunpoint and
they lost all their equipment.
So elegant angel.
I don't know what the name of,
I think it's happened to a bunch of them.
This was a small company that was a startup company that this my,
my friend was renting a house from this guy and this guy's like,
dude,
you can't miss.
You can make some money.
It's going to be huge.
So he and his dumb ass.
He goes,
yeah,
yeah.
It sounds awesome.
How many,
you know,
one year I'll give you 100% return on your investment.
You know,
and you'll,
you'll own a piece of the company.
The company's projected to be making this much money anyway.
He loses everything you $30,000 he takes out of his credit cards.
He gets like a $30,000 loan or whatever he does.
He loses everything and then just decided to go bankrupt.
So he just goes crazy for a year,
for a year.
He just uses his credit cards and doesn't pay anything but the minimum and just
runs them up to the gills.
Just goes crazy at strip clubs every day.
He was getting lap dances at strip clubs.
He just lived like,
like a savage for one year and then he went bankrupt.
I can't do that anymore.
You can't do it.
They made it hard.
Yeah,
they made it very,
very difficult because,
um,
I know a dude who,
uh,
tried and he couldn't,
he tried to go bankrupt.
He owes a lot of money and they're like,
yeah,
you got to pay that.
Like,
sorry,
you're fucked.
You're fucked.
A 40 page,
go bankrupt.
You should probably pay these bills because it used to be you could,
oh,
like a fuck load of money.
Right.
I don't know.
Okay.
I wonder what they did was they went,
they knew they were going bankrupt and they also knew that in Florida you can
claim bankruptcy,
but you're allowed to keep one house.
So what they did was they took all their money and bought these gigantic $30
million fucking houses.
These fucking palaces paid,
paid them right out and then claim bankruptcy.
And I'm gonna get this.
They still sitting on 30 million.
Whoa,
calm.
Connie sees the house and say,
well,
you'd have to live with you or not in Florida.
Yeah.
Every state's got their own funky little rules.
Why Florida is a haven for gangsters.
Okay.
Florida is the best place to be a pill junkie.
It's the easiest way to get pills.
It's,
it's a nice straight highway to New York.
If you drive the speed limit,
chances are you won't get pulled over.
You can do all your creepy shit that you have to do and you can live in the warm
climate.
You know?
So they,
there's a lot of laws that go down in Florida.
If you go to Miami,
they'll tell you factually there's more banks per capita in Miami than any other
city in the country.
And the reason why is because that was what they used to process all the cocaine
money.
They use those banks.
It's that simple.
Florida is a gangster state that that state is just dummies and gangsters and no
one decides to kind of go and sort it out.
Right.
There's too much craziness.
And Florida,
Florida,
like every time you hear about somebody,
serial killer,
nutty shit happens that grow fucking killed her baby.
That Casey Anthony Bench.
It's on to the Florida.
Yeah.
Floor.
Fuck.
Yeah.
It's always,
whenever you hear Nancy Grace,
talk about some shit.
It's always dead babies in Florida.
I'm going to jump to Suzanne.
I do,
ah,
whatsapp time.
His ex girlfriend,
his girlfriend Russell has been with me.
Let's rephrase that.
What?
Wait a minute.
We've been friends for quotes on the Daily Mail.
Russel's been with me.
Dot Dot.
Dot.
The Daily Mail.
Mal.
Well,
this is hate speech.
Right now what we're doing is hate speech.
We might have to apologize.
It's just like Tracy,
Tracy Morgan,
um,
fundamental stab them to death,
right?
The story is even more depressing to me then the Tracy Morgan and because I
hadn't heard,
hadn't heard about that.
And I think that's the worst part about it.
It was like,
you know,
they had to make an example out of somebody that says,
Joe hasn't been on the air yet and Tracy is,
that's horrible.
It's still ridiculous though.
It's totally ridiculous because he was reacting to something and he at the
[inaudible] heat the moment,
but it was something which was not planned,
not kind of written down anywhere beforehand.
Tracy's routine was established that I don't think he wrote that apparently did.
They didn't really aren't retracing.
Maybe.
Probably not wrote it down,
but like Jay Z,
Jay z doesn't write his lyrics town either.
Even though you don't.
Right.
I can't physically I'm too lazy.
That's really my reason.
I had a shape.
Joe.
I'm fucking lazy.
Why do you think that I need,
which is a pain because you kind of forget routines and the rhythms.
No,
it would help,
man.
You don't even have to write that down.
But what I started doing that I really enjoyed is just writing blog entries.
I started writing a lot,
a lot of like,
like little essays for my blog.
I fucking love it.
It's a Joe Rogan daily.
Not,
not.
That's just a program that picks up links from my Twitter.
I don't have anything to do with that.
Oh really?
Yeah.
All I did sign up for that and then people I follow on Twitter,
it picks up links.
They tweet.
Yeah,
and it's random.
So,
but I follow a lot of interesting people,
but I had to stop following a bunch of months because there'd be a bunch of
stupid shit would show up on my daily and I'm like,
bitch,
you embarrassing me.
Right,
right.
And I had a kid,
she read it like I,
I tried it a little bit here and there,
but then I'm like,
you know what?
I read his Twitter and I was on Twitter yesterday.
I posted yesterday
that I really want it to click the link on and I haven't done so yet.
Man,
I'm addicted to Twitter and I'm addicted to getting information from Twitter and
so many fucking people on Twitter send me.
Cool Shit.
I mean is a,
is an incredible resource.
Right now I'm at 378,467 people,
which is way too much for me to really be paying attention to all of them at
99,000 and 90,000 well this is is are a lot more than me.
I was at Kevin Smith's place yesterday.
He's almost got like 2 million.
I think he's way the fuck up there.
Wow.
But there's so much,
there's so much comes to you when you have that many followers.
It's real hard to like keep track of all of it.
Like I'll,
I'll leave the room,
I'll go somewhere,
I'll come back in an hour and a,
it'll say 900 new tweet messages.
So then I'll have to try to like,
just try to do my best to see if there's anything in there.
Certain people that you will look at.
Kevin Smith level.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of people that I look at their shit exclusively because that guy
was pretty funny.
Some comic probably or some guy wants to be a comic.
Yeah.
It's probably a guy who wants to be a comic is comics generally don't tweet.
Funny Shit.
You were saving it.
I didn't see you in Toronto until the fights,
right?
Yeah.
We hung out in Toronto with this girl who uh,
has a funny a thing on.
Oh yeah,
you were saying?
Yeah.
We're trying to find,
her name is Kathleen Slash Lien slashing.
Anyway,
I forget what her,
uh,
her online,
name is,
but it's fucking hilarious.
And she's kind of like,
she has like 50,000 fucking followers or something crazy just from doing funny
shit.
And then people think it's funny and so they,
uh,
they were responding and retweet to it.
You know,
it's a,
it's a weird resource man.
There's nothing like Twitter has ever existed before where you just,
you're constantly getting new crazy stories from all your friends and newt
lengths.
And I mean,
I get it for news and everything.
It's crazy.
My cable went down the other day.
I had to at t and t Uverse and it went down for like eight hours and I was like,
what the fuck?
I can't even go on line to find where to go to see what's wrong.
Your Uverse was taken away from me.
Yeah.
So,
so I went on Twitter,
on my iPhone and it was like I just typed in,
I searched a Uverse and it was like 50,000 people just to go on man.
Fucking their service.
I just called,
they said it was gonna be down to 5:00 AM,
you know,
just people talking about how is that Uverse so you liking that and just suck.
I love it too.
But they just started capping it.
Yeah.
And the,
all the,
all of them are now like capping and uh,
they're supposedly monitoring your,
what,
you know,
how much Netflix you use and stuff.
But I act like I don't know all this and haven't been affected by it
because when you say cabin,
yeah,
it's not like anybody's listening.
When you say capping,
what do you mean by camping?
Uh,
that like if you go past a certain amount of download,
you download so much per month that they will either start a slowing down your
internet speed or stopping it.
Sure.
This is how funny this bitches,
this slash lien check that I told you about,
I just went to our Twitter page.
It's slash Lien Sla.
She's not even a comment.
She wants to be a comic but she can't commit to it.
Right.
I'm such an alcoholic.
You can legally drive.
You can't legally drive after eating me out.
That's hilarious.
That is funny shit dude.
I was such an alcoholic.
You can't legally drive after eating me out.
Dude,
that's a comic.
She's a,
she's a comic that just hasn't done it yet.
There's a one
Gary Delaney in the UK and he normally tweets is his one liners.
He,
that's what he does is just one line as he stands up.
He's a stand up here in the UK and not all he does all day long is just tweet
new one liners.
Which contract act.
What do you depend on?
What response you get from people that if they're following
what,
what does it,
I don't want to,
I don't want to blow my Pontiac training.
Delaney spelled d.
I like good for like kind of like a timeline now.
So like if you do have an idea for a bit,
you put it out there.
So it's kind of like timestamps.
So if you hear some guy like two years later go,
you know,
Listerine,
some of those lines,
defibrillators are special machines to stop children lying.
Gary needs a hug.
I wrote that down.
Gary.
Whenever I see an ice cream van,
I always like to say,
you'll never get anyone to the hospital going at that speed.
Oh,
that's a,
uh,
that's a kind of a flip of a,
we have a comedian in the UK in the 17th cold milk and more wise,
and there's a sketchers they did where a police call,
huddles,
huddles path and I,
you know,
the sirens blazing,
whatever.
And because they'll never,
they'll do have to sell ice cream at that speed.
Oh,
I see.
So it's a flip of that.
Wow.
You have to be deep into the whole English sit of mine.
That's like a Benny Hill joke.
Yeah.
Okay.
Stephen.
Right.
We're talking about this yesterday.
Is writing a novel on Twitter?
If you don't know,
it goes dry and Steven,
right?
Yeah.
He's literally writing a novel on Twitter every day.
He,
uh,
ads.
Yup.
Long time and TBC to be continued as at the end of almost every tweet.
It's the most ridiculous shit ever.
157 counties.
Yes,
exactly.
And then it's TV sake.
It is the most ridiculous shit you've ever seen in your life.
It's really hard to believe that he's actually committed to doing this.
But it's fascinating,
you know,
that's one of the many uses.
How often do you use the Twitter?
I'm not a,
I'm not that a diligent,
I read it more than I tweet it.
Do you ever tweet jokey things?
Like what do you put on it and that,
you know,
I'm mostly,
I think I'm most active when there's a fight on really.
I give fight commentaries the whole time and I think they're pretty,
people find them fair,
fairly entertaining as far as I can tell.
Do you do comedy fight,
fight?
Uh,
yeah.
You know,
I'll say it like,
uh,
what was his name?
Just fought fucking two weeks ago.
Just had dinner with my agents.
I paid,
uh,
what was his name was just fine.
He dropped down in weight,
dropped down to featherweight and UFC.
Oh,
Kenny Florian.
I was,
I said wow.
Ben Stiller looked really great and no fight.
How about Sam stouts knockout though.
It was crazy.
That was fucking,
it was scary.
It was scary.
Yeah.
There's a certain amount of times where a guy gets knocked out where it becomes
easy to get them to get them to shut off and Sam style can really punch.
He's a good puncher,
but I didn't like the way you've went out like that disturbed me.
I mean he got caught perfectly but it just seemed like,
man that was a bad knock out.
That was a bad one.
That was one where you really got to assess whether or not you're done.
How are these guys going to,
yeah,
cause you know there's certain shots at the guy who gets hit with like you.
Like of course that knocked him out.
Like when when Gabriel,
Gonzaga head kick cro cop.
Like,
that's just,
that's one of those shots we get hit by that you go out,
you know,
it's just how it goes.
That's natural selection.
But then there's certain shots like when,
when,
uh,
rich Franklin knocked out chuck Ladell and they're fine.
They're the right hand that knocked him out.
You're like,
wow,
that I don't think that would have knocked chuck out five years ago.
Oh,
you know,
but it put them out.
Now you've got a crack on your chin.
That's exactly once and it's done.
What protection do they have in,
in UFC?
That's it.
And your wits.
Yeah.
You have a gum shield shield come from fucking grinding.
Yeah,
but what about,
but no jock.
Strap pull.
No.
Yeah.
You were a cop.
You were a cup.
Yeah.
You were a cup smart guys.
There's a,
there's actually a,
a,
a cup I'm going to try out tonight.
It's called diamond MMA.
The develop some new system with a compression short to keep the cup from moving
on your balls.
It's like,
keeps it all like slammed up.
Sneak out.
Yeah.
So even if you get kicked,
you're not going to get hurt because there's been a bunch of guys who have been
really hurt pretty fucking badly from cups sliding into their balls.
But apparently they say that the,
the best solution is the old time way.
The Ty Cup,
the Thai Cup,
they would tie on and it's made out of steel and this steel cup,
they just mash your balls into it and tie it in place like really tight.
And that's supposed to be one of the best options to old school Thailand style
bro.
With a big fucking steel shield over your Dick and balls and old tie Cup Cup.
It's got a calendar.
I'll tell you what,
man,
I enjoyed watching Strikeforce this weekend cause I didn't have time.
I was doing a show.
I,
Ooh,
I have Grand Prix.
Yeah,
well Josh Barnett just destroyed Brett Rodgers.
He ran,
he ran through it,
man.
I mean he's said Brett Rogers is a really tough guy,
but he doesn't have those skills.
He doesn't,
he's not,
it doesn't have a real ground game.
His striking game,
he's rudimentary.
He just hits hard,
you know.
And that's,
that's what he's good for.
And He needs,
he needs a comprehensive overhaul of his game and against the grappler,
like Barnett Barnett is too strong on the ground.
He got them down to the ground,
just smashed them.
And then the second round got him in an arm triangle and he tapped even before
he got to the side.
Oh,
by the way,
I want to ask you about that.
Uh,
did you notice that it looked like the Santo is tapping as the fucking bell
ring?
Junior dos Santos?
Yeah.
Someone had said that before.
I didn't think it looked like when I watched it right there I go.
He had fucking,
uh,
Carmen had him in that fucking choke.
Real good.
Yeah.
And,
and as it was literally,
it was like this and,
and then his hand was like,
right about to touch his,
literally like,
it was like Dang.
And it was like,
and he let go and he was like,
even he looks shocked.
Like he's not sure if he,
you got to watch that back right at the last,
if there was three seconds more in that fight,
there was,
he would have tapped,
oh fuck yeah,
that he had of it.
I would have to see it again.
There was no getting out of that too and he hadn't been in somewhat of an
Anaconda choke in it.
I have to see it again.
Even if you fucked up with this with what would you guys have gotten?
Broken arms,
broken legs,
knocked con on.
The guys got knocked unconscious.
No one's died.
Okay.
But they've got real good safety precautions and the referees are good at
stopping fights and what's really dangerous when you see a boxing match,
but it's really dangerous.
It's not just getting hit once.
What's really dangerous is heading blows that don't knock you out exactly where
you get knocked down and then they count you to the count of eight and then dust
your gloves off three or get back in there and the UFC.
If you get cracked and dropped,
the guy jumps on you and hits you again.
If you're dazed,
you're going to get knocked unconscious or you're going to get days to the point
where the referee has to pull you off and believe it or not,
you are actually safer that way it's going to save you a tremendous amount of
punishment.
So if you get like dropped and rocked really badly in the fifth round,
but somehow or another you,
you managed to stand up and by the count of 10,
you get your wits about you just enough to hold on and then you get dropped
again the next round and they get dropped again the next round.
Those are the fights that really can fuck a guy up and kill him.
I've seen it more likely though.
We're a guy gets,
uh,
it gets knocked out with a punch and he hits the canvas and the other guy jumps
on him and hits him again and actually wakes him the fuck up.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's the truth.
Um,
people always say that,
that I knocked them down and I woke him up.
I think I've seen,
I've seen the guy hit and I go,
oh fuck.
He's out and then hit some of them.
The guys all of a sudden,
okay,
he might've probably jumped out anyway.
See the problem with it,
it does.
It doesn't coincide with the,
the natural reaction of a concussive blow.
The national reaction of a concussive blows not to wake you up.
It's just shut you down further.
And if you have a tendency to get shut off,
especially if you've been shut off before the,
your,
your brain actually recognizing that as recognizes that as a pattern.
So it's,
Oh,
we're under attack again.
The shutoff and preserve all functions and just let everything go.
So I don't think it really does wake you up.
Are there many surprise?
I might be wrong though.
Seen it happened.
Like when it looks like the guys out on the way down,
it might just look like,
it looks like he's out on the way down and then he hits and then Bam,
and then he,
and then he starts to react again.
But are there any surprises in the UFC fight?
Can you kind of predict
who's going kind of come out the winner?
No,
there's always surprises.
It's one of the most shocking sports ever.
There's always something that happens in freaks you out like this,
this fight between Todd Duffy and Mike [inaudible] and Mike Russo is a,
like,
he's got a lot of body fat on him and he's a,
he's a big fucking tough guys,
a Chicago cop,
but he looks like,
you know,
like a guy like privately played football in college,
but now he works,
you know,
as an accountant and he likes to eat a lot of sandwiches,
you know what I'm saying?
But this Guy Todd Duffy,
it looks like he was created in a laboratory.
I mean he shredded sculpting and he's got this fucking big captain America.
He man jaw and he just looks like the last motherfucker you'd want to fight.
Just looks like a super athlete.
And this guy,
Todd Duffy puts a beating on Mike Russell for two and a half rounds.
Wow.
And then the third round,
Mike Russell connects with one punch at a nowhere and Todd Duffy goes off.
Boink shuts completely off,
falls to the ground.
And Mike Russell hits him one more time when he's out.
Wow.
Yeah.
He hits him all the time,
by the way,
with an arm that was broken in the first round.
He got kicked in the arm and the first round was broken arm.
Mike Russell and Todd Duffy,
I dunno,
maybe a year ago,
I want to say a year somewhere around UFC.
Incredible fight.
Ridiculous turnaround.
One Punch,
knockout,
unexpected.
No one saw it coming.
This guy,
Todd Duffy looked like he was a future contender.
I mean,
you look at him and like,
this kid's a fucking destroyer.
I mean,
look at this kid like,
how do you fuck with this kid?
He's like 250 pounds moves like a gazelle smashing people.
He just looked like one of those guys.
It was just going to launch it to the top of the heap like really quickly.
All of a sudden out Kohl's one punch.
That's how crazy this sport is.
It was the other one with the guy that knocked him out eating a sandwich at a
time.
He could have been,
he's just one of those fucking tough Chicago guy.
MMA fighters have a shorter shelf life than a boxer does.
Probably.
Um,
their training is way more rigorous probably,
but then the way longer and harder.
But if you look at Randy couture and he lasted a long time,
you know,
I think he's down to the rule.
Yeah,
you're right.
It's not so bad when he lost in Toronto,
man,
it was a bad one.
I got teary eyed to come.
Well,
you know,
I didn't feel sad.
It was a crazy kick.
I didn't feel sad because the guy had a long and storied career and goes down as
one of the grades and was saying,
you know,
hey,
this is a real big challenge and if I could beat this guy,
um,
you know,
I'm,
back in the hunt and maybe I get a shot at the title and you know,
he was thinking crazy thoughts.
You know,
I was thinking like,
hey,
you never know.
You know,
or this could be my last fight,
win,
lose or draw.
Like I heard a bunch of different stories,
you know,
but to have him go out like that,
like at least with an exciting loss,
you know,
just get kicked out.
I mean you got dropped and he got his teeth knocked out and everything,
but he's not a part of history.
It's like,
it's almost like has to go out that way.
It was a big rest dance.
Everyone just lost,
but he's just got it.
Yeah.
He just lost,
he just got knocked out by some really tough young kid and this tough young kid
is like,
uh,
you know,
in his thirties think maybe even younger dentists ever stop talking about
couture's age.
Right?
He's older.
He's in his 50s.
Wow.
Yeah.
I'm still fighting.
Still finding was still active.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's not,
it's a young man's sport dude.
That's for fucking sure.
I had a conversation with Forrest Griffin about it recently and he was talking
about how when he was younger he would fight totally different.
Like now he thinks about it like,
fuck,
this fucking guy is going to hurt me and this,
this could hurt my fucking shoulders hurt.
Yeah.
You start to second guess should,
yeah.
We started to think,
to start to be intelligent.
You start,
do you start to also like combine risk and reward and calculate them up and go,
hmm,
what's in this for me?
You know,
especially you see that in a lot of fighters that really,
realistically we'll probably never be champion.
You know,
there's a lot of guys that you see them and they're like,
well this guy is just,
he really doesn't have the skills to ever beat a guy like Anderson Silva.
So what happens to him,
you know,
while they slowly somewhere along the line lose the fire.
Is John Jones Fighting Anderson?
No.
Jon Jones is going to fight rampage.
I could could take rampage.
Uh,
I think it's an exciting fight.
Rampage has got some fucking history,
man.
He knows a lot of shit.
Does anybody want a coconut water?
Oh,
these coconut water.
So you've been doing any deejaying lately?
I,
yeah,
just got that DJ APP on my iPad.
I've been fucking around with deejaying in my house.
That's true.
Nice.
Thank you.
Hi.
Uh,
I've been teaching
and my house actually haven't touched the turntables and a couple of days I'm
actually going through withdrawals.
So when I get home tonight,
I'm going to go out to dinner with,
uh,
with the family.
You Dj in your house,
like you have people over and have sparring fuck around by yourself.
Yeah.
That's like hitting a bag.
Keep yourself sharp.
You ever get one of those boxes where it's just tons of different,
uh,
sounds like you can program each thing to do it.
Yeah.
Oh,
sound the little a and they're like all colored the,
I know what you're talking about.
The um,
we have to see color doses.
Don't say black.
It's a faggot.
Barks
retract that statement.
But yeah,
I was looking at those late,
like thinking about,
that'd be cool to like program maybe controller.
Yeah.
That's it.
Many controller,
colleague,
no.
Yeah,
they're cool.
I don't know.
I don't fuck with them.
I have this thing called the dicer,
but you attach to your turntables and then you can hit your cue points and then
you can loop shit right there.
That's always,
it's fun for me.
Cause something else to play with.
Have you ever mixed like your act into music?
Because that's what I was mixing a Jenna Hayes's Mons,
the orgasm sounds and two songs and I thought it was kind of interesting doing
it man is I,
I did Lopez tonight a couple of weeks ago,
about a month ago and uh,
and the guests were,
uh,
Paul Stanley and Randy Jackson.
Paul Stanley from kiss.
Yeah.
And I was the biggest kiss fan growing up,
so I was like a little girl that day.
Anyway.
So,
uh,
do you think that the guy from kiss it had some work done?
No,
not at all.
Certainly natural.
Naturally pulled face.
Yeah.
Everybody lives like that when they're 90.
Everyone got it comes real hair color too.
This is totally real hair color.
So Paul Stanley joins the house band.
Uh,
that night starts playing.
Then Randy Jackson grabs a base and starts playing with the house band.
And then we had already set up my turn,
my laptop and turntables to be there.
So I joined the band.
I started scratching with them,
but I was scratching Lopez,
his voice.
Oh,
that's awesome.
That's good.
It should be on youtube somewhere.
Oh,
that's cool.
Cutting it up with them.
You Love Dj and,
Huh?
I love Chang.
Wow.
I too thing if you ever have a private party and you,
I will fucking DJ the shit out of.
That would be awesome.
When's your birthday come up with a reason to have a private party now.
My birthday's in August.
Let's have a birthday.
August party.
Maybe I'm going to find out if I'm around.
That would be,
that would be bad ass dude.
Where would we have it?
Where would we do it?
Wherever you want to do it somewhere.
Cool,
Brian and suggestions.
Uh,
she's having a fucking party,
man.
We should have a once a year sort of a festival.
It doesn't have to be my bird birthday.
But why don't you tell him about,
why do you have an official Joe Rogan after party after one of the fights?
Vega.
Maybe you've done that a few times.
Yeah,
we've done that a bunch of times,
but we've done that at clubs too.
We know like in Vegas where they will supply,
you know,
set you up a place.
Yeah,
I think,
um,
I was with buffer at the last one at uh,
excess.
Yeah.
We're talking about may buffer and Forrest Griffin and Jake shields and she has
dance together.
We totally slow danced.
Nice.
Say something and he's a grinder
and it would,
we were talking about the gathering of the Juggalos the other day about how it's
fascinating that these guys have managed to way to get all these disenfranchised
kids and,
and bring them out and you know,
and,
and give them something to do,
you know,
and have this like this,
this festival where everybody gets together.
I'm like organizing something like that though.
Like would actually be kind of fun,
you know,
organize like having one like one weekend somewhere or one,
one something,
some sort of,
uh,
you know,
some sort of a holiday sort of,
or something to it.
I don't have to,
I'm Russell Peters is down.
I'm down here down.
Which should we do?
I don't know,
but I'll be playing classic rock,
funk,
disco and hip hop.
I like it,
dude.
It makes all that shit together.
I do.
I know all vinyl or you do digital?
I do it all digitally because it's too fucking much music to try and carry all
those records.
Yeah,
that's ridiculous,
right?
Oh,
it's loud as fuck.
You really gonna hear the compression.
Somebody sent me something that three,
three 90 bit like that.
There's,
there's really high bit rate fucking navy freeze here.
They sound distorted and loud.
Do they?
Yeah.
It's turning up the volume.
It takes too much space on your iTunes.
Does it?
How much it would be like 10 gigs are still takes a lot.
A lot more.
I took all my iTunes and and betrayed them.
Lowered them all to one 20 or something like 1.8 yeah.
Really?
But my a fuck about me and my music for deejaying is at a higher bit rate
quality.
It's around two something.
Two 50 so for yourself,
you,
you give yourself less than you give your fans know for for my,
for my iTunes,
that is correct.
For my iPod and you get less.
But when I'm playing for you it's all about you.
That's what I'm saying and I'm saying is with,
if I'm playing your party,
there will be no music played that was made after 2000 really?
It'll be all pre 2000 nice.
That's the century.
I got a problem,
man.
I,
if I have the choice between listening to something from the sixties or
seventies or something from the,
the,
you know,
the current era,
I always go with sixties and seventies it's some longing for nostalgia or
something.
Yeah,
it takes you back to a different place.
It's a different kind of music man.
It's a different,
you know,
it's like when you listen to is like some Allman brothers from the 70s there's
just an,
I don't feel like the same vibe when I listen to music today just doesn't sound
the same.
I saw John Fogarty jogging the other day on Mulholland.
Whoa.
That was fucking cool.
And as soon as I passed him,
I put on CCS scream out bone on a by you.
I said,
I put,
I put on a on when have you ever seen the rain?
As soon as I passed them.
Didn't he get like some sort of a serious legal dispute like his former manager
and like crippled and financially I think he was in some big fucking throw down.
Like he made that song something can't dance but a steel yum on a watch him or
rob you blind.
He made a song about this Gal.
Was that why he was joking or not driving?
Yeah,
maybe man.
Yeah.
That's why he's not in CCR right there.
There they too are,
but there's a CCR.
It's Creedence Clearwater revisited.
Really?
Yup.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
How could you have credence Clearwater revival route?
John [inaudible] well,
journey has a,
the Filipino guy who who's singing for um,
for,
where's the guy then the regular journey.
He's Perry.
Where's he?
He's like,
I think his voice is shot.
No Way.
Something happened to him with his voice.
Oh No.
So they've got this Filipino kid who was in a journey cover band in the
Philippines and they heard him and he sounds exactly like Steve Perry.
No.
Well it's pretty fucking his name.
Is Arnold something that you think we could play that on the podcast?
Why not?
You can't cast anymore to Sirius radio,
satellite radio now.
So we have to watch it.
We don't get sued.
This is how ridiculous they are.
We got to get our own insurance
and we can't play music.
Yeah,
that sucks.
Cause all the freedoms we have in America though.
But I wanted to,
especially with you on,
I wanted to play some music cause the last time we were walking we played some
fucking riff and he picked out some beats in this song that we had to go,
what?
We had to like that platform and we got to go CSI on this fucking thing to try
to hear what you picked up like instinctually.
And that was,
I can hear those stupid sounds even with low bit rate,
low bit rate and I can hear it.
I'm trying to find this John Fogle to thing,
but I can't find the,
the legal troubles and looking forward on his,
uh,
his Wikipedia.
But it was a,
I know he made that song about the guy,
you know,
something about something.
Can't dance or it's still your money.
What are you doing there fellow?
I was,
go ahead.
I think of a song if it's CFA.
Russ was ever heard this,
but you can't play music young file.
I'm just going to say what the name of this can we hollow?
It's okay to play music if it's yours.
I see what's going on here.
Why I oughta major lazer.
How great is the major Lazer?
Major Lazer?
Yeah,
Dave really redoing the three stooges,
cause I keep telling her that they're redoing the three stooges.
I heard that on the TV movies.
She isn't Steve Sort of,
uh,
I think of Steve corrals playing one of them too.
Wow.
No fucking way.
That seems like a terrible idea,
doesn't it?
He might even be playing Mo.
I don't think you,
no,
no.
You have to say no.
If someone wants to,
Justin Timberlake was booboo and the Yogi bear movie.
What?
That Yogi bear movie that came out recently,
right?
Wasn't Yogi bear after Timberlake,
uh,
animated thing.
Yeah.
It's a classic movie though,
or classic character that's now Justin Timberlake.
Yeah,
but it's not because it's a voice.
It's not like he's playing Larry or curly or mo or even shrimp.
Sham.
I liked champ Schempp didn't get any credit.
It was a Marx brother's got a fairly brothers movie.
Is it?
Yep.
There you go.
Who's playing it?
Does it say Sophie Vergara?
Sofia Vergara.
I did a movie with her son.
How hot is that bitch and
girls that just have that look man,
that they put on the unit.
The cool thing about her is she's cool as shit.
Wow.
Do you live the about Kleenex?
I've gone through because she doesn't have to be that cool.
Did you talk to,
I have to be aggravating.
You can be a little cunty and it's tolerable.
No country there.
Hot as fuck.
God.
She talking too shabby.
She's so high that it makes you uncomfortable.
Like you're looking at it.
You just go over for food.
We were supposed to have a kissing scene and whoa.
And then the uh,
director posers,
I guess.
Sorry Sophia didn't sign for that.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
son.
She wouldn't sign for a slow dancing scene instead,
or that's okay.
She's so printing and it isn't she like 42?
Yeah.
She's nerdy guy.
Yeah,
it's time I saw her.
She was in an episode of entourage.
God pushy when they first went down to start doing medean.
Ah,
she came into and then the Billy Walsh falls in love with her and then,
um,
it turns out that vent fuck through and all that kind of,
whoa.
I don't remember that.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
And entourage entourage.
That movie's getting show is getting more and more unrealistic every year.
Right.
Can you imagine that?
That's where I,
yeah,
and then we have Vince fucker.
Yeah.
Put that in there and then he becomes a werewolf.
Then unicorns coming out of the carpet.
She was in brothers.
What does that does it the Marky mark movie?
Yeah,
with Marky Mark Tyrese.
Tyrese tweets who were too much.
I had to shut them off.
I had an we're following Tyrese.
Oh yeah.
Beautiful.
And inspirational trees.
This is a weird way to find out your cage.
Inspirational tweets.
They love when people reverend run.
I follow him.
I love really condescending,
inspirational tweets that a lot of guys will do to women.
Like ladies,
you need to look out for yourself and be strong.
You know,
if that man can love you for who you are,
he can't love you.
Period.
Capitalize.
There's something about that sort of like cheesy,
low level pimping.
It's low level pimping and it makes me laugh.
Comedy shows as well.
When the guy goes,
okay,
come on,
put your hands together for all the beautiful ladies here.
It's about three attractive woman in the entire room.
Every time I do a black room,
I always hear where the independent get your,
if you're independent you should be at fucking doing something independent,
not watching a comedy show.
How come nobody looks for the freeloading bitches?
Are they with the free loading bitches?
Well that was one of the beautiful things about the Kanye West Song.
I ain't seen she's a gold digger.
This,
uh,
there's a a certain amount of people that just,
they just know yeah.
Or they are follow 50 cent on Twitter sometimes.
His Shit's funny.
Yeah.
He says some funny shit.
He talks a lot of shit too.
Yeah.
He's,
he's seems like he's having a good time.
I don't think he takes himself too seriously and I think he realizes he's
fucking lucky.
Shit is making a ton of money off that fight him and water more than anything
isn't that 400 million off of sane amount of money retired.
He asked for a piece of vitamin water when he was like promoting them and then
it became this sheet Uhg fucking company.
Well,
now he's got a chunk of it.
Wow.
There's things like that.
I mean,
all you have to do is just call water vitamin water and people are like,
oh,
they're just so stupid.
They're just,
it sounds like it's good for you.
Yeah.
It's just,
it sounds like it's good for you.
No,
we're doing it with our tweeting,
checking it.
We can end this.
If it's boring the fuck out.
I don't want you to,
you know,
I'm just checking for you buddy.
Checking to make sure everything's Okay and making sure the world is moving at a
nice pace.
Is Everything okay out there?
Um,
it's looking like it India and Pakistan.
Are they going to go to war?
You tell me.
Do you have the inside skinny?
Um,
you know,
that's what's going to happen after the cricket,
cricket,
cricket match against each other.
They played each other in the,
in India,
one by one.
Cricket in the World Cup.
How important is cricket to you guys?
To me,
not personally,
but in India it is the biggest thing.
And that's their super bowl dude.
Yeah,
huge.
I mean,
we're not as known as athletes.
What's,
let's face it.
You have some great wrestlers.
Do you have a great history of wrestlers?
We do.
Um,
but however,
um,
subsequently wrestling training too,
you know,
and like,
I didn't a martial arts start in India originally.
Who knows where it started.
You know,
there's,
there's a bunch of different started in Asia,
most likely.
But you know,
there's also speculation.
It might have started in Africa too.
What else?
Nobody really knows Zelle down to the ground.
But if you go back in time,
you know,
the Japan is probably the place where the most damage was done,
where the most,
uh,
shit was figured out.
But you know,
martial arts in the year 2011 or stronger than they've ever been.
We know more about martial arts in 2011 than anybody ever has for sure by a long
shot.
The,
the martial artists have just two decades ago,
can't fuck with the martial arts stuff today.
And I was no,
no comparison.
And there's never been anything like that before where something has evolved so
quickly and dramatically in our lifetime.
Yeah.
Martial arts is basically the automobiles of,
I mean the way it evolve know technology and the way that people figured shit
out better.
Yeah.
Similar.
But it's weird,
you know,
unlike computers,
basically it's been around for thousands of years,
but for thousands of years when you fought,
we didn't have the luxury of fighting for sport.
You know,
when you fought it was cause you were fucking try.
Yeah.
You're trying to stay alive for thousands and thousands of years,
so you didn't have the fucking,
the time to be training twice a day and taking taekwondo and you know,
and,
you know,
learning Jujitsu and Rio.
And I think the shift that people are going to taekwondo or karate or some shit.
Yeah.
Bruce puffers got a black belt in taekwondo.
I'm throwing some quick.
Jesus Christ.
You fucks.
This is what I get for Nada.
You guys hear what Roger Ebert said about that guy,
that jackass guy that does he say,
he said something like,
uh,
don't want friends.
Don't let Jack asses drive drunk or something like that.
Did he really say that?
Yeah.
And then Bam said like,
look,
I've been crying all day.
You know,
how dare you say something like this?
Fuck you
apologize.
Will,
you know,
it'd been just dropped from Michelle or [inaudible] book dropped his profile.
Roger Ebert or they pulled his profile,
but then they put it back up.
Um,
you know,
I guess the cracked under pressure and then they,
the one with the,
uh,
no jaw.
Yeah.
This is Joe removed from cancer.
You know,
it's,
it's a fucked up thing when someone dies that way.
But you have to also say,
hey,
you know,
you,
we have to let people know that you're not supposed to be fucking driving trunk.
So you know,
your friend dying right now is the time to have the most impact on people
possible from a news event and for people to step out and say,
yeah,
hey,
you shouldn't be fucking driving drunk cause you don't just kill yourself.
You fuck kill a bunch of other people.
And you know,
and who knows who was driving.
He might've been the other guy that was driving,
but I understand that this dude's friend died and he's crushed and he's hurting.
He's crying all day.
But it doesn't negate the situation.
It doesn't mean as a human being,
I think we have an obligation when someone dies in a fucked up way as a comic
especially,
we have an obligation to talk about that shit.
We've got to flip it on its head.
Yeah,
you have to.
And as a society,
even though I'm not a big fan of critics,
I'm not a big fan of like the shit that Roger Uber does for the most part
because I think most of what they do is just negative,
snarky bullshit,
you know?
I think they have an obligation to step up and to say something about,
about a situation that they feel strongly about like that.
That's a big issue,
man.
Yeah.
You know,
I see.
I know what Bam saying,
but you got to,
if that was my friend and my friend died drinking and driving,
I would go,
you're right.
You shouldn't drink and drive,
man.
You shouldn't.
This is fucked up.
It's crazy.
I lost my friends more fucked up.
Is that a,
Brian was more upset about Red Ben.
I mean Ryan Dunn Dying.
Then his cousin who got run over six months time now.
No devastated or sad about Ryan Dell.
I had to stop thinking about it.
It's,
it's like I never met her and you know,
my niece,
it's my,
like Stephanie's.
Anyways,
it's,
it's it.
But,
you know,
I don't hang out with my niece ever,
except on holidays.
But it's just more so it's to me,
it's kind of like,
it's more outside.
Like I don't know these people that well and it just kind of disturbs
me.
I keep on thinking about it.
I don't even think,
think about it now,
you know,
brought it back home.
[inaudible] Jackass Guy.
The time a big rehash or something about those jackass guys
dying outside of a jackass stunt that seems like almost like,
you know,
how the fuck did that happen?
It almost seems unfair.
Well it's Kinda like when Steve Irwin died from us thing,
ray,
well it's still fucking around with animals.
You know,
I got a lot of people got mad at me cause after Steve Irwin.
Dot.
I said,
uh,
what did I say?
I said,
I go,
uh,
the world loses one.
That wacky animal guy in my act gains 10 minutes.
I don't really see the loss.
It's really a Douche bag thing to say.
Uh,
and I didn't think about it cause then I thought about it afterwards.
I'm like,
Oh,
this guy's got kids and he's got a family.
And what if they saw that?
And so I actually,
uh,
I,
I put a,
it was all just a post I've made him,
my message board actually took it down and then I wrote something based on like
how I really felt about the guy.
But what I really fail feel like in,
in a situation like that,
it's like you Kinda have to make fun of the situation because that guy was doing
something that we know you're not supposed to do.
He was running up to animals and fucking around with them and pythons and cobras
and lions and the,
the most fucked up dangerous animals on the planet and his Gig was that he would
feed crocodiles while he was holding his baby.
Do you remember that shit?
You,
Jesus,
you think,
think you get,
you mean,
we know he wasn't completely in control.
He fucking died at the hands of an animal,
you know,
but his shtick was that he would put himself in extreme danger.
What would make you incredibly uncomfortable and you know you're supposed to
like what?
When the guy dies,
you're not supposed to say anything.
You're supposed to be quiet.
No,
you're really supposed to make fun of them.
Yeah,
you fuck.
You're not supposed to do that.
God Damn it.
You're not supposed to be feeding crocodiles while you're holding a baby,
but you know how the crocodiles going to move you.
Fuck.
That's craziness and it's his own bay.
Oh Man.
Is it true that bringing back fear factor to bring in my favor?
Congratulations.
We're talking right now trying to get that done on paper,
son words then.
I Dunno.
I can't be hosted by anybody else.
We'll see maybe forest.
Mario Lopez has an engaging smile in a way about him that makes you want to tune
in and maybe Mario could do it.
I don't know,
man.
I might do it because it's very possible.
I got to get that right by phone.
I'm just so busy too right now with the UFC,
but if they comment that it on paper,
we'll see what's up.
I least give Joe Rogan some long paper.
I'm only in this game for one reason.
Kids on paper have you seen me?
Premiers with fur coats on and giant pimp habits.
You know what's up
and a lot of Mondays all around your arm.
One day,
I remember when we were in,
uh,
Georgia and this girl was calling black people elements,
elements,
elements.
We were in a,
we were in Georgia and we were asked to the show we were going to leave and we
said,
hey,
is there a good place to get something to eat around here are good bar.
What's,
where's the place to go?
She,
well this place
is okay.
But well they got the elements there and we were like the what the elements are
there.
The elements like,
you know,
like Pete was like fucking fire tornadoes.
When you got earthquakes,
you got you to get together and produce a glossary natural of shit that people
cook.
Black people be where white people were figured out.
Oh,
another word.
Other than nigger.
Exactly.
The eye.
The eye nick for the Iphone,
you can have your name.
Yeah.
Well that's,
I bet that would be offensive to people.
That's right.
Junior high,
my Negro.
That would be,
yeah,
but isn't that offensive to people?
Like there's a lot of people that are going to think that calling someone a
Monday it's going to be offensive because it cause it Tuesdays.
Cause the distinction is that the black,
I think white people are Tuesday.
I think Tuesday would be Asians for some reason.
There's Day.
Yeah.
Has a yellow hue to,
it sounds to me like Tuesday would be the Asian.
Oh Geez.
There's a group that's shy on comedians.
I mean they're starting to pick up the pace over the past decade or so,
but the Asian could we get Johnny [inaudible] who's the dude?
Henry Cho that talks,
showed a southern guy.
He's still rock that southern accent when he,
that's only he,
it his real voice.
That's really how he talks his Margaret Cho still still performing.
Yeah.
She's still around.
I believe she almost fucked Ari.
Shaffir whoa.
Really?
Yeah.
Or should fear was gonna they were gonna throw down.
Literally might not be supposed to be talking about this in the podcast.
I love Margaret though.
She knows a lot.
It was a culture.
Hey,
is that the beaver we got that chewed up on your IMD be there at the beaver.
Is that a real movie that Mel Gibson movie?
It's really coming out.
It's supposedly isn't it?
And it flopped.
Yeah.
It came out.
It opened up in Germany,
I believe.
Yeah,
Germany opened up May 19th and that's,
I don't think it should,
it has an open in America and what's,
I mean if you're going to say antisemetic Marsha,
might as well open up in Germany.
Test the waters.
Yeah,
no shit.
If that really opens up Germany,
that's hilarious.
Wow.
Do you know how funny then is if his movie really opened up in Germany?
No.
It looks on,
see the problem.
It looks like I'd open up everywhere,
but it only opened up like total,
like 22 screens and then it,
oh,
then it went to 168 screens.
Nobody wants to see it,
Huh?
Yeah.
It's definitely low budget movie.
I don't think it's a low budget.
We lead all,
it's Jodie foster and Mel Gibson.
It was just 19 million.
No,
it was,
it was made right when I'm the shit.
It was done right when the shit went down with him and all those audio
recordings and then there were,
they sat on it for a minute.
Yeah.
They sat on it for like a year,
right?
At least.
Right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
So this is a movie that he,
he,
does he have a puppet act or it,
you can pop it that that talks for him because he's fucking crazy and he's
ruining his life.
So he uses this puppet sorta pick up the pieces and get his life in order.
Is it like a remake of magic,
the acne help cubes movie from the,
well,
he was a ventriloquist and knee.
The dummy kind of took over.
Oh No.
I think that was when the dummy one wind up killing people and shit.
No,
that was way more fun.
Yeah.
This is,
this is a pet beaver.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like a,
a puppet that is meant to be,
that talks about his children in it.
Yeah.
What would I be able to speak to them through the beaver?
I like.
What is that?
You know
I won my daughter's back by speaking to them through the beaver who was in the
room.
I got,
she got green.
You've got to pee again.
Let's just wrap this bitch up.
It's fine.
Look what they said that they said,
that Jackass Guy,
he crashed going 130 miles per hour.
Oh,
wasn't he driving a Porsche nine one one if I remember.
Wow.
Jesus Christ there.
130 miles an hour.
I don't drink.
I've never drank.
But what goes through your mind when you're thinking to self that,
okay,
I'll been,
you could do anything.
The problem is when you're drunk,
close that door.
We want to hear your purse,
motherfucker.
Okay.
When you're a,
when you're drunk,
you're not thinking,
and that's the whole idea that the beautiful thing about alcohol is it takes
away your inhibitions.
It takes away your ability to think that good too,
though.
It takes away everything Ebert's face.
Roger Ebert said that was probably too quick to tweet.
Mm.
Yeah,
he fucked up.
He said,
he said,
yeah.
I mean that guy is all negative,
man.
Oh,
I would be too.
I was watching that Stephen Hawkins movie or show on a Wifi network.
Have you watched any of that?
It's a where he kind of narrates the meaning of everything.
I think it's what it might be new.
Yeah.
What's it called?
Stephen Hawkin.
It's called Stephen Hawking's.
A guide to everything or something like that and all the writing it.
What was really Steven,
what,
what does or doesn't say.
They have them out there and they'll have them like talking like this and then
like a narrator kind of blends into it so that his voice turns into a different
narrator.
Dude could easily be like the technological or futuristic Tupac.
We could keep his album's coming until the ever Stephen Hawking think going to
be long dead.
They could weekend at Bernie's that motherfucker and just keep coming out with
new audio books is Stephen Hawking.
And so new discoveries that I've found in my lap,
anybody want just speak and spelled correctly,
he's dead as fuck.
And I think that,
I think that Chafee Moga what's wrong saying that thing?
Wouldn't that be crazy if he's not saying shit and all these other physicists
are using him and it's like an inside joke.
They push him around and they control his little thing and they call them the
beaver and the beaver.
I think that you should fuck this guy over here that there was this a part
though where they,
he starts off talking about,
you know,
like gravity,
like how the tr uh,
apple falls from the tree and then like there were the,
the,
the guy that director was making it look like all these apples are flying all
around Steven hog and he's just there in his wheelchair.
And it's so funny because he can't move or anything.
So like there's this person behind him like throwing apples down behind them,
you know,
cause it's supposed to look like this tree is just dropping on Abbot.
I hope you get to see his little eyes like twitching.
Like what am I doing here?
These apples I really fast one.
If he could disagree with that.
If he has that in his contract,
I don't think this is the best way to get my point across.
One of these apples are going to help me imagine if the greatest minds of the
last decade dies by Apple.
They're doing a fucking stupid commercial and an apple fall on his horn to tell
him on the head he couldn't walk again.
What the fuck?
What did you guys do?
Because I'm feeling awesome.
That was great.
The issue spoke feeling.
If they fixed that guy who would just go on a pussy rampage just start fucking
everything.
Can you imagine if they came out some stem cell shit,
they shot it into him and all of a sudden he looks like a 30 year old athlete,
which was for reversing blindness.
Yeah.
Isn't that insane?
Awesome.
Yeah,
and meanwhile this is the shit that the Republicans tried to fight off during
the,
all the Bush administration tried to stop as much of a stem cell funding as
possible.
All this crazy Christian fundamentalists who thought that you're going to steal
babies and use their tissue and encourage abortions and people are having
abortions,
whether you like it or not,
hooker,
don't you think the baby would be far worse off in its state of existence if you
don't even do anything with the tissue.
But if you use the tissue abortion's a bad idea to go to Detroit Cha.
I think birth control,
birth control is certainly the best option.
Once you have kids,
man,
the idea of killing a baby,
even if it's only three cells inside your body,
it's kind of freaks you out.
You know?
Because like you realize if that kid got out of there and then you were raised
in it,
man,
you would love that fucking kid.
So the idea is sucking that kid up with a vacuum.
You know,
once you've had kids,
you know I'm a dad.
Yeah,
it's an intellectual sort of a debate.
And you know,
I,
I always say the other right to choose.
I say,
I cannot tell you what to do or what not to do with your body.
And if you want to suck those three cells out with a vacuum cleaner,
that's one thing.
But as a person who has kids in you,
you start realizing,
whoa,
three the fundamental idea behind it is there's a life inside of you.
I mean,
there really is a life.
I think you should be able to do whatever you want to do.
I'm not,
I'm not saying I'm right.
I'm not saying I'm trying to impose my,
but that life has been created and it's going to come out.
And when it comes out,
it's going to be a person.
And you could s headed off at the pass with some scientific trickery and suck
that little cat with a vacuum cleaner.
But you can't kill the debate as to what you're doing.
You know,
I'm not saying that I'm right,
but I'm saying there's a debate and there's a lot of like left wing people,
a lot of pro choice people who do,
do not want to approach that debate.
And they say,
no,
a woman has the right to choose.
I mean,
you're just,
you putting some words to a,
uh,
a situation and you're defining that situation by,
a woman's got a right to choose.
Oh,
she's got a right to choose to stuff,
a vacuum cleaner,
upper pussy and stuck out a baby kill it.
Is that what you're saying?
No,
that's not what we're saying,
but that's what's happening.
When the baby gets to be a certain age,
you're sucking that baby out of a pussy with a vacuum cleaner.
I'm not saying that I'm right.
Um,
but I am saying that,
you know,
no one,
they're not being really honest about what it is.
You know,
everybody wants the right to have an abortion.
Can,
you know,
write your rape victims should definitely have,
fuck yeah,
they should.
Rape Victims,
incest victim.
I'm not saying that there should be no reason for them to keep me,
dude.
I'm not saying that everybody shouldn't have the right,
I just say the deer is a debate and I don't think the debate has been completely
free.
I think every woman from about,
you know,
who grew up in the,
anywhere from the eighties onwards,
I think every chicken you've ever dated had an abortion at some point.
A lot of them have,
I would say 90% of the women out there have all had enough.
Really.
You think it's that high?
I ain't get that.
Oh my God.
Let's just say that many women have had an abortion.
Little bit.
A lot of them had a,
I didn't go ahead an abortion.
I did it.
A girl had an abortion.
I had a walker to the clinic.
It was fucking dark dude.
Cause there's all these women in front of the clinic and the have signs and
shit.
Same Shit.
And a lot of the signs are actually like,
like still birth babies,
you know,
it's like they're not even a aborted fetuses.
These,
these are like,
you know,
babies that died and you know,
and it came out of the body and they're just misrepresenting it in photos cause
they're ultra gruesome,
you know.
And then there's pictures of babies that the claim had been killed by abortion
vacuums.
They're all broken up and in pieces and they're sticking them in your feet.
Keep your baby,
keep your baby,
you know,
and they'll do that.
And there's,
there's situations where,
uh,
I know a guy who his wife was,
they,
the baby was still born inside of her and she had to go and get an abortion
because the baby was already dead inside of her and you know,
I could kill her and kill her.
And there were screaming all this shit at her as she was going into the clinic.
You're killing your baby,
you're killing your baby.
And the husband was fucking furious.
He was like,
you know,
my fucking babies already dead inside of her.
You can't get the fuck away,
like screaming and yelling.
And they're all,
and they,
they're claiming they're doing it for Jesus to which is the most hilarious.
Yeah.
Fucking valet guy has nothing to do with it.
The Valet Guy,
hey series together approximately.
Oh,
Russell.
And I tell you,
I lighten it up a little bit at the end.
I know we went down abortion boulevard,
we went down abortion board and parked in the mud.
It's a fucking dark subject.
They're going,
we should have bought that assumption quick too.
Good call,
good call.
It is.
It is tricky and I'm not saying I'm anti abortion.
You do whatever the fuck you want to do,
but I am saying it's weird.
No
was really weird.
I think I talked about this before.
I used to work at this restaurant in this eye,
this guy who worked there,
I used to always carry around pictures of his dead baby dressed up and close it.
Like it was born like premature,
like three after three months or something.
Like it was just like a really small baby.
Like it was not,
it didn't even look like most of a baby and they the kind of look like they died
and they dressed,
they dressed up in these clothes and they took pictures and I carried them
around in their wallets and they actually showed people as if it was alive
still.
And it was,
you know,
those people are assholes.
You're freaking people out on purpose.
You know what the fuck.
If you go online,
there's tons of websites where it's this like,
like different clothing.
Like the,
that people do like put different clothing and like make it like as if this
baby's still alive.
It's like they're honoring,
honoring it with different clothes that they have bought.
And that can be good mentally for it.
No,
I don't think it is either.
I don't think you have to have clothes.
You need to kind of say,
okay,
fine.
This closure,
it's fucked up.
You need to,
you know,
move on.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing man.
People are fucking strange if you've thought of it.
There's a community online dedicated to it.
Whether it's dressing up,
dead babies are,
or what the fuck ever speaking to communities online.
Peter's,
what's your website?
[inaudible] dot com two s's.
Two L's.
Sorry.
How can people reach you?
Uh,
I'm on Twitter at junior Simpson and also there's juniors,
Simpson,
just normal normal spelling or jr uh,
no.
Uh,
Jay,
you the full thing.
Junior Sampson,
junior Simpson at junior,
which was for Twitter and a genesis and.com.
Powerful.
Thank you for joining us guys.
It's been a lot of fun.
If somebody,
when one,
can anybody see you do some stand up?
If they could possibly get a fucking ticket.
Funny enough,
funny you should ask Joe.
Um,
this Saturday I'll be in Seattle.
Shazamm we're having the new majority.
Two are with me.
Lisa Lampanelli and Gabriel Iglesias.
I was staying at the w hotel in Boston,
which is right across the street from the Wilbur theater.
And I saw your beautiful mug on that screen over and over again advertising an
upcoming show,
right?
That was that show.
It was that same thing,
right?
Yeah.
And what is it called again?
What's the name of the tour?
The new majority of the new majority.
And it's you Gabriel Lampanelli burn opens it up to powerful lineup fingering
somebody.
Will you really nice.
Everybody needs a hobby.
Okay.
This Saturday night,
June 25th,
Carnegie Library Music Hall in Pittsburgh.
It's me and Joey Diaz.
Tickets are going quick bitches.
So hop on that.
And then the very next weekend,
July 1st we are at the Mandalay Bay theater and Las Vegas and it's me.
Sam drove past that.
Ari Shaffir is going to be there.
Joe Diaz.
Doug Benson is going to stop in Brian Red band.
We might get him drunk and throw them on stage as underwear or something.
Some shit's going down.
All right,
so Pittsburgh this Saturday night,
um,
Vegas next week and I may try and get the fights too.
Oh yeah.
Are you going to July 2nd and let me know man,
I'll,
I'll make this happen.
Sweet.
Russell Peters in the house.
Thank you very much sir.
Always great to hang with you.
Peace.
God Junior.
Very good to meet you,
my friend Youtube.
Thank you very much everybody.
We'll probably be back tomorrow.
If not,
I'll see you next week.
Ah,
suspense.
Who knows what's happening and follow me on Twitter.
And if you don't like abortion,
she should fuck a flashlight.
And if you go to Joe rogan.net we want to thank the fleshlight for sponsoring
our podcast.
And if you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the fleshlight entering
the code name Rogan,
you will save 15% off.
All right,
so fresh flashlight.
You want a real one?
I got a fresh one,
man.
That's the alien one.
Do you want one smell?
You want one?
I got one for you.
Can't bring that home.
Can't bring it home.
My wife will keep it in the car.
Just fucking in the car.
All right.
Powerful back.
Love you guys.
Thank you again.
[inaudible].